what did you call this the podcasting
booty call we come together for a very
intense 3 hours don't see each other for
six months until I text you again and
say what you doing it's exactly that all
right so we're going to go through some
of the best lessons I've learned from
you over the last couple of months first
one control freak is a word people with
low standards use to describe people
with high standards you're not a control
freak you just want it done right the
first time you're not anxious you care
do not expect mediocre people to support
worldclass
goals I think most people feel really
lonely when you want something that
doesn't currently exist and so some
people call that dream some people call
that goals whatever it is you're trying
to pull something from your mind into
reality and you want it done a certain
way and if it's not done that way it's
not what you imagined and so people on
the outside will throw stones and call
you names that they think will change
your behavior and get you to stop and
and the more I have been the person
trying to pull things in the reality The
more I've tried to weather and build
kind of defenses against those things so
that when those stones get hurled at you
by being called a control freak or by
saying you micromanage things or that
you have incredibly high standards the
answer is yes because I want it done
right the first time because either way
we're going if you have enough will it's
going to get done the way that I want it
to get done regardless and it'll be less
painful if we just do it the first time
because we will still have to do it and
you may have to do it three or four more
times but eventually you'll just succumb
to the fact that we're going to do it
this way and I think all of the great
things that have happened for Humanity
have been from one man or woman who had
an idea and just wouldn't let people
shake it from
them the standard of right isn't
actually that insane when you think
about it it's just right it's just done
without
error and I guess that
the margin that some people consider to
be right and other people consider to be
right just
changes I'm trying to think of a really
good example for this but
like the level of detail I mean it's
it's the difference
between it's the difference between a
book that gets 10 or 100 festar reviews
and a book that gets 100,000 festar
reviews and everyone wants a silver
bullet but most of the things that make
great products is 100 golden BBS and so
that's one of the things we have is
there's no silver bullets only hundreds
of golden bbb's there's just hundreds of
tiny little improvements it's like how
can we look at the can how can we
improve the way it ships what about the
weight what about the color scheme how
does it sit on the shelves how are
people going to look at it in this
market versus this Market are like how
does this name appear on hats and on
shirts and on and on sites and what's
the RGB you know whatever the color SC
scope is here versus there and it's just
a thousand details that someone who does
not care will not put the work to look
into because they're trying to check a
box rather than to make something that
people will love or um I heard this from
shoot I can't remember where it was from
um but basically that the best art is
Art where the artist makes it for
themselves and where you see commercial
work is where a bunch of people are
trying to make something for an audience
and so it's they're trying to like rinse
and recycle stuff that actually solves
no one's problems because no one is
actually the audience whereas when you
make it for yourself there's thousands
of people just like you who will who
have the same depth of understanding of
it but it feels selfish in the moment to
make something for yourself but when you
make it for yourself you actually make
it for everyone but you can be reliably
informed that there's some non
insignificant minority of people who
also think like you yes who also have
the same problems as you who also have
the same fears as you so I'm going
through two projects at the moment one
being a book and the other being UT
tonic that is nent and it's new and that
means that there's lots more of these
small things that are actually quite big
things but I was telling you before we
started about the fact there's a hyphen
and there's a hyphen missing between one
piece of copy and another piece of copy
but it's printed on a million cans think
for [__] sake
but being concerned about being seen as
someone who has too high standards is
something that for quite a while I felt
ashamed about yeah because you feel like
a
bother you feel like you're being
necessarily it's not even detail
oriented it's picky cumbersome yes yes
yes yes laborious um and I realized
probably last year took me until last
year to realize that not succumbing to
stopping doing that is probably one of
the only reasons why I've had any
success I mean I think if so for anyone
who's listening if you have that I I
would considered a gift um it makes
sense for the majority of people to be
opposed to that because you do make more
more work for everyone
else but the product of that work is so
much better and so if you want the work
that you have to last and to be
meaningful and make an impact it comes
from a 100 golden BBS of 100
particularities of 100 peculiarities
that you are picky about because the
whole thing needs to work and what
happens is if you have a big project
lots of people have to get involved but
there still needs to be one vision and
otherwise it looks like a Frankenstein
where everyone just checks a box of
something they did in the past they just
copy and paste it over and then it
doesn't resonate with anyone because
again they just did it for everyone
rather than for the artist and so using
that as a frame has given me permission
to be me in an unreasonable world and so
like I told I told this last time I was
on but when I did the book launch I had
I I practiced that
presentation three times a day every day
for 30 days so I did a 100 run throughs
full length run throughs first where I
did it out loud and recorded it second
time where I would watch the recording
um and then edit in real time and then
do it again and I did that every single
day and so then when I came live and had
half a million people or whatever it
came out I think flawlessly but people
were like man you're such a natural at
this it's like well I did it a hundred
times and so sometimes people even hear
100 it's just a big number but when you
do a 100 repetitions of something the
first five times you're like wow I'm so
much better but then like the difference
between five and the next 95 times is
what goes from being great to being a
masterpiece and like it's that next 95
that I think is what makes people world
class and that's where everyone falls
off and that's why most people aren't
there is this pull I think from people
who don't have high standards to people
who do have high standards to drag them
back it's this like uh moving back
toward the mean yeah
is killing the only competitive
advantage that you
had couldn't agree more
it's I mean it's it's conforming right
it's like they people want you to do
what they find comfortable and most
things that are like most companies
deteriorate when the founder leaves
because and it happens slowly because
it's you go to from 100 golden BBS to 99
golden BBS and it doesn't look that
different and then there's 98 golden BBS
and they're like I don't know and then
two years later three years later you're
like I don't know it doesn't have the
same like magic as it was what it was
and that's because the art behind it
isn't there because it's not unified
anymore it's not congruent anymore it's
a 100 departments making decisions with
people copying pasting things for an
audience that doesn't exist rather than
one person who's trying to be satisfied
for an ideal that they are trying with
all their might to live up to I suppose
this is one of the important reasons to
have a singular figure that is the Hub
and all of the spokes come off it
because they're the only person that
gets to see absolutely everything and
typically that would be the founder in a
podcast that would be a host in any
other in a um solo music band that would
be the lead singer or the songwriter or
whatever they get to see everything for
instance we've done some episodes before
where it's been the night before and
I've been not happy with the color grade
because the way that something displays
on mobile is slightly different to the
way that it displays in Premier Pro and
it's slightly different to the way that
it displays in a 6K photographer
videographers curved screen I've gr guys
it's like it's not up to scratch well
we're not going to be able to get it in
time for the export we're not going to
be able to get it in time to get it
uploaded and then there's checks that go
through on YouTube like
well it needs to happen like it just
make find a way to make this happen and
yeah that um that impulse of just
actually seeing it as something that you
should lean into okay well it's not and
if you set the standard and if everybody
else gets up to that standard what it
shows is the people who continually push
up against that and don't meet that
standard they're just not built for this
particular company they're built for
someone else that makes a mediocre
product but they're not built for you
who's making a world- class prod and I I
I really want to jam down someone's
throat right now um the whole like don't
be a perfectionist like you're proc like
it's just another word for
procrastination I actually think that's
complete [__] I think that that's my
quote being is it perfectionism is
procrastination masquerading is quality
control yes okay so then I'm going to
I'm going to put us sub a sub footnote
on it that I think will will add context
which is that most people who claim to
be perfectionists are not perfectionists
they're actually procrastinating because
they're not doing anything and so it
just is a socially acceptable label
because the real perfectionists feel
this this sickness where they like want
to itch their skin off until the thing's
done but they are trying to get it done
whereas the perfectionist or the the
procrastinator uses that to say like I'm
not sure I'm just getting it right but
like the person who's an actual
perfectionist one wants to finish and is
working every hour of every day on the
thing and seeing progress towards it
because if you don't know how your thing
is getting better you're not a
perfectionist you're just ignorant
they're also moving toward the goal
every single step of the way as opposed
to just sitting back I had this huge
list of things that are not doing the
thing planning to do the thing isn't
doing the thing thinking about the thing
isn't doing the thing getting angry at
people on the internet that have already
done thing is doing the thing and um
there's also
a people who are perfectionists within
the thing that matters most are prepared
to see things that are anciliary to that
for instance you're not absolutely a
perfectionist I'm going to guess with
the short form content that goes out on
your Instagram it's like this is sawdust
as you call it this is just it's extra
right it's it's it's freebie stuff look
if we have one in a 100 videos that have
got a a typo or The Hyphen missing or
something
all right but if we're talking the
school announcement release if there's a
fcking typo in that or in the the video
one of the links is broken or even if
one of the links is slightly pixelated
yeah that's something that I can have a
problem with so picking your battles as
a perfectionist I think actually or
someone as someone with high standards
is super important because you can't
have that degree of high standards at
absolutely everything because if you
don't pick your battles you're not going
to make sufficient movement at the
velocity you need to actually make so
find the areas that are the highest
contribution
yeah don't compromise on those and it's
funny you say that because I the way
that I immediately reframed that was
that the perfectionism was around volume
it's like that is what we will that is
what we are optimizing towards and then
we can't because if we look at if we
knew how people responded ahead of time
to content then we would make things
differently than we do but I probably
like you am often surprised pleasantly
and sometimes unpleasantly by the stuff
that just grabs hold and then just goes
you know viral as hell um in content and
so I think part of that is making up for
our own Ignorance by increasing volume
and at and so that would be like it my
reframe on the perfectionism there is
like we know that if we make 10 pieces
of content it is more likely that we
will have more people see it than if we
try really hard at one and so we make 10
because the net benefit of the 10 is
and so that's the ideal that we commit
to Thiago Forte has a fantastic take on
this where he talks about perfectionism
allows people to sit back and not
produce work at a rate required to work
out what actually works have you heard
the the story of the the pottery class
oh I feel like the all right wellow I
this feels like total modern is this
where someone comes in behind and then
holds the thing in front so there's two
two uh there's a teacher and he's got
two classes that he teaches and one
class he said says the only assignment
for this whole semester is that you come
with a come back with a perfect uh clay
pot that's it that's the assignment the
other class he says your objective is to
make the most total quantity of clay
pots and you'll be measured by how many
pots you make and at the end of the
quarter the pots that came from the team
that had to just make sheer volume not
only did they make more pots but the
quality of all of their pots was better
compared to the teams that only had to
make one and it just under lines the the
biggest lesson that I've learned in my
life which is that volume negates luck
is that you can try to be lucky and pick
the one perfect thing and try and make
it but if you don't want to try and be
lucky you can just do so much [__]
work that you will you will brute force
your way to figuring it out like if you
do a thousand podcasts you'll be pretty
[__] good at podcasts right but if
you try to say okay you're you're rent
you're brand new and all you have to do
is make one perfect podcast the problem
is that you don't have to perspective
itive from which to make a judgment to
say what is good because you have zero
data to base anything off of and so
you're basing your idea of a perfect
podcast on something that you've
literally never done before and so doing
the volume gives you the perspective to
then have the best podcast at number
1,000 or 1001 anyways I just thought
you'd love The Clay Pot I I know that
story but I thought it was photography
oh okay so anyway but no I I again I
don't disagree and it's finding the
thing that is to try and make this
tactical what is the thing
that you don't need to focus on volume
today the goal is not to try and fit 10
podcasts into one set it's to make this
one as good as possible but if it's
shorts or reals or tweets or something
it's lower leverage it's lower input
just get just get it out there all right
next one here's how to get older without
getting better keep relearning the same
lesson if you keep making the same
mistake over and over the mistake isn't
the problem
you
won't so I Define learning by same
condition new behavior and so when you
go to a video game and you battle
through the level and you battle the
boss if you keep doing the same thing to
the boss and you keep losing then you
have not learned because you have the
same condition and the same behavior and
so I often say that like for anyone
who's listening to this podcast if the
goal is to get better and you're like
man I really want to learn something
from this podcast if you listen to this
podcast and then you're in the same
exact conditions as you before and then
you do not change your behavior you
learned nothing and so using that
definition has at least allowed me to
change my behavior faster which then
goes into rate of learning which I
Define as intelligence and so a lot of
people are like man he's so smart but he
just doesn't it's like well then if he
doesn't change his behavior and he's in
the same conditions he's a dummy he's
not that smart and
so if you are trying to battle the same
boss over and over again and you don't
change what you're doing and the boss
keeps beating you then it's not the
game's problem it's your problem you are
the problem and I think that's um like
if you if you continue I talked about
obviously I'm I talked to a lot of
entrepreneurs but I usually do this when
I have a crowd I say like hey raise your
hand if you work all the hours of the
day and a lot you know most of the crowd
raised their hand I say okay who here
has been stuck at the same Revenue level
for 6 months or more and then I said
keep the hands up and like honestly most
of the time the same hand are raised and
say you're doing the wrong [__] like if
you put all your inputs and the outputs
haven't changed then you have the same
condition and the same behavior and so
you have learned
nothing and so that has always just been
my reframe and so over time if if you're
moving up in entrepreneurship or you're
moving up in
career your behavior should change
because it means you've learned exposure
to information isn't
learning great deal
are it's true it's true and it's the
same with memory it's literally the way
that memory works the best way to work
out how the human memory system works is
repeated recall not repeated exposure
right you have to drag it out of memory
and use it not just see it a million
times and this is kind of the same thing
with the lesson it's you can listen to
any of the podcasts that exist on the
Internet or the ones that we've done or
the ones that you love or whatever
and if you don't apply anything it it's
a waste of time and this
is the best solution for this is Tim
Ferris is the good [__] sticks look
what's the thing from the podcast or the
book or the audio book or the the
whatever that you read or listen to that
you can't stop thinking about that you
go to bed and you think about it that
you took a screenshot or a screen
recording and sent it in the group chat
that you like texted your mom about it 3
in the morning oh this really explains
the way that I felt in school or the way
that I felt when such and such broke up
with me or whatever that's the thing
that's the thing to focus on but a lot
of the time the me the problem with
mental masturbation is that the amount
of information you can intake versus the
amount of change that you can deploy is
asymmetric yeah when I was getting
started on my um entrepreneurial journey
and I would say this like pre this I was
when I was a entrepreneur like I hadn't
quit my job yet I started reading all
these self-help books and I remember
reading like it was probably like my
10th book in a row and I realized that
the words in that book contradicted like
the second self-help book that I you
know one was like it's it's all about
goals the other one's like it's all
about taking you know steps or whatever
it was right and I and I all of a sudden
I was like you know my life is the
same I've read all these books but my I
I still literally live in the exact same
condo in Baltimore doing the same job
like nothing has changed and so I just
made the commitment that whatever the
next book that I was going to read I
would just not read another book until
i' done everything in that book um and I
that's when I quit my job and I did a
whole bunch of other things and um I've
actually more or less stuck with that in
terms of like when I read books or even
listen to podcasts I usually do it with
an intention to get something out of it
and um I usually have notes up and so
that's so my intake on information
because because I get asked a lot I'm
sure you do like I actually don't read
that much um I definitely don't read
non-fiction I read like fantasy every
once in while Red Rising baby that's
right um but it's because usually I get
overwhelmed with the amount of things I
would have to do and so I'm like I don't
need more information I'm like I'm like
I could read a chapter and be like all
right that's it I like it'll take me two
weeks to do this and then like the rest
of the time is doing that and so how do
you ensure that the things that you're
reading are giving you good advice
because if you didn't move on before you
took two weeks to go and do the thing
but the thing was dog [__] you've spent
two weeks going backward so I would
probably I would make the argument that
I wouldn't have gone backwards cuz I
would have gained the experience and so
I would have more context to know what
the second thing was going to be and
that's just kind of like the trial by
fire learning through iteration and I
think I tend to do more of that um sort
of a all learn philosophy yeah and I I
would say that like there there are
entrepreneurs who are definitely like
super super duper planners and there are
entrepreneurs who are more like let's
just move and break [__] and we'll
figure it out I tend to be really this
on the micro in terms of like move [__]
and break you know like we'll figure it
out as we go and I just tend to be a
planner only in the big like very Grand
like what do I really want to do in 10
years but the majority of the time it's
like let's see and we'll we we'll learn
I've learned so much like so much of the
content that I have comes from just
[__] up in business and people were
like this is such original concept I was
like this is just cuz that's what my
life was I just like I made this mistake
and it didn't work but I said this one
thing one time and then all these people
bought and I was like ooo how do I do
that again and so like it was always
through iteration and I I I read all
these books but there's just between
knowing how uh or sorry knowing that and
knowing how like knowing that maybe this
works maybe but once you do it it's a
different type of learning where at
least for me it's about been that way
you could read you could read a 100
books on sales but when you take your
first cold car all of that goes out the
window because you actually have to you
actually have to sell we'll get back to
talking to Alex in one minute but first
I need to tell you about element element
is a tasty electrolyte drink mix with
everything that you need and nothing
that you don't stop having coffee first
thing in the morning your adenosine
system that caffeine acts on isn't even
active for the first 90 minutes of the
day but your adrenal system is and salt
acts on your adrenal system element
contains a science backed electrolyte
formula of Sodium pottassium and
magnesium that helps to regulate your
appetite curb cravings and improve your
brain health this orange flavor is
absolutely insane it is the best way to
start the day it's a beautiful salty
orangey drink it's refreshing if you've
been doing hot exercise and it's just my
favorite way to wake up I've been using
element every single morning for over
three years now and it's still just as
enjoyable as when I first used it right
now you can get a free sample pack of
all eight flavors with your first box by
going to the link in the description
below or heading to drink LM nt.com slod
wisdom that's drink LM nt.com
slod
wisdom this is related to something I
wrote last week don't be so worried
about people who imitate your work they
only know the what but not the why if
you stopped being creative so would they
a photocopier isn't an artist even if it
can recreate the Mona
Lisa I love that because you think like
you you are Source in that situation and
so everyone is there for like a subset
of you
and they require you to live you don't
require them and the equal opposite is I
think we should be more fearful of when
everyone stops cop copying you like the
day that no one copies you is far far
more frightening than the day everyone's
copying you yeah Jimmy car refers to
China as a cover
band you know great it's like they're
the cover band of The Beatles And he
says you know they're they're good and
in many ways they're able to produce
things at more scale and so on and so
forth but they're not driving The
Innovation forward in that same way yeah
the idea of getting upset about people
copying is just ridiculous
like yeah that's all I that's all you
understand why it's painful right if
someone's gone through okay let's test
and test and test and test and test and
then finally find a particular form
formula that works and then 10 people
Downstream get the benefit of this hard
laborious effortful late night grind and
iteration and they just got to be like
oh that thing
yeah I so I think that like they they'll
be able to copy what they can see but
they won't be able to copy what they
can't see which is understanding why
each of those pieces are in place and
when something changes in the future
they won't be able to iterate from there
because they don't know why it was there
in the first place why right and so like
I mean I've obviously dealt this with in
a business context where like real
dollars are at stake and so like in the
gym world you know gym launch for those
who don't know I had a big licensing
company we had 5,000 locations and
anyways so we had basically business
processes that we would you know iterate
and figure out why this worked and so
then I had I I used to keep a list of
names and then I just it got too long
and tiresome to keep the names of all
the people who tried to take the stuff
and then sell it as their own um I say
their I say their names every night
before I go to bed you think I don't
remember you I remember all of you um
and
so none of them 10 years later are still
around and not and none of them even
came to a tenth of the sze of Jamal and
it was because it wasn't theirs like the
person that I would be far more afraid
of somebody who comes out with a
significantly better system than what we
had to help gyms make more money and
help their you know help their clients
more um but like to this day like
they're still isn't one and that one's
Tim lunch is still the category King in
that in in that industry and so it's
like just and that's because we put and
we were talking about this earlier
everything is an R&D for us and so we
actually like were the only licensing
company that had an R&D department and
we would test uh we call them plays but
we test plays every every 14 days and so
we'd spend 50 or 100 Grand on just a
test we would be like all right let's
test this new marketing campaign or we'd
say hey let's test this new uh High
ticket sales processor hey what if we
did what if we tried to sell memberships
via chat let's just give it a shot see
what happens and and
honestly 70% of the time it would it was
worse than the control like it didn't
work as well and what we would do is
we'd present it to the lenses and say
hey guys guess what we just spend 50
Grand on that you don't have to spend
money on look at the results of this
sell membership yeah yeah the thing is
is that most people are actually really
happy to to know that it didn't work cuz
it felt like they were scratching it
like oh great I don't have to do that
one like someone did that test for me so
anyways um all that to say uh unless you
have that that trail of bodies behind
you that led you to figure out this one
thing when there is a kink in the system
because some external condition changes
which it always will they then don't
know which means you're always still
going to be ahead yeah that's very
interesting yeah
because if you understand the physics of
the system if you understand the
Dynamics of why you're doing the things
that you're doing and something changes
you can respond but it goes back to
people with high
standards you have to presume that you
win in the weeds yeah you have to
presume that you win in the weeds and if
you do and if you're continuing to be
this close to it yeah as soon as things
change you go that's interesting why has
that
happened and that then allows you to
continue to iterate and you see it cuz
you're in the weeds right somebody who's
all the way zoomed out just like yeah
copy paste that they're like they're one
they're late cuz they have to see that
it's working see that it's working
consistently so they're already 3 6
months behind then they start trying to
figure out how to implement it and then
they start implementing it and then what
they don't see is the things that made
the conditions that made it work to
begin with and so like if you just
assume that you're always in the lead
then it means then sure second through
10th place will always copy number one
but to the victory go the spoils and so
you like no one gives a [__] who is
fourth place at the Olympics
reminder that if you want to be
exceptional you're going to be different
from everyone else that's What Makes You
exceptional you can't fit in and also be
exceptional both have discomfort when
you fit in you have internal conflict
because you're not being 100% you when
you're exceptional you have external
conflict because everyone sees you as
different pick one when your friends
start to say you've changed remember
it's because they don't know how to say
you've
grown
I Define words a lot because it helps me
kind of like made sense of the world and
um like exceptionals is like an obvious
one right we use the word exceptional
like you are not like everyone else um
but even saying it like that like you
are not like everyone else and so if
someone someone says you're not like
everyone else then you can just reframe
that as like I'm exceptional and that's
not a bad thing um and most and I I
don't and I actually think that most
people have like this might be counter
to most people's beliefs but I think
most people have the potential to be
exceptional and I because most people
are peculiar in their own way they just
stifle that because they want to be
accepted by most people but in so doing
never accomplish what they want to do
because they conform uh and so like if
there's probably a lot of things about
the world or even your world around you
that you're like this never made sense
to me but then you do it anyways and I I
think that a lot of innovation and a lot
of what makes people exceptional is
feeling you know thinking that thought
or seeing that thing and then being like
huh I don't think I'm going to follow
that rule
anymore like why do I need to shower
twice a
day huh like I don't know like why do I
need to wear different
clothing huh like there's just a lot of
these social norms that people people
you know usually pass down to us or
they're you know bred into us in high
school and college and things like that
um but it's like you see a guy who you
know wears a cowboy hat and dress a
certain way and he basically wants to
say I am this I am this archetype of
person but if cowboy boots aren't as
comfortable for you as New Balances are
and you know that and you still wear
cowboy boots I would call you a fraud
because like that is like it's a it's
like a micro Rebellion against yourself
it's like there is and like I look at
old people a lot because usually they
don't give a [__] anymore they've just
like given up and uh there was a survey
that they did where the number one
reason that old people like don't have
as much drama and they're happier is
they say they they cited they literally
don't have time for it like literally
they don't have time for it and I found
that so interesting and I was like well
if I'm going to eventually be that way
when I'm 80 I might as well just start
being that way now and so they usually
wear like really comfortable Footwear
and like they they keep their
surroundings like whatever weird
peculiarities they have they just accept
them and so I think a lot of like if if
life is a long journey of
self-acceptance I think the earlier you
can accept your own peculiarities as
just part of you rather than trying to
justify them or mold to what you to the
archetype that you think is acceptable
within your Social Circle um at least
for me like there's this period of
discomfort when you change anything
because everyone around you wants you to
fit within the label that they are
comfortable with but they also have the
anchor of what you were before yeah
exactly and so they try and like they
they people don't like that and so
they're like no no I like you in this
box so just say I I know you're having a
little thing right now don't worry just
just and they just want to shove you
back into it and there's there's a lot
of uncomfortable conversations that you
have to have where it becomes really
socially awkward um and so like I I said
one the other day about like going home
for the holidays and the reason I don't
like doing it is because often I have to
confront a lot of people that I haven't
seen in a long time and they'll speak to
me in a way that I don't like and before
that I would roll it off like whatever
no big deal but but um I don't accept
that didn't you torpedo a family holiday
a couple of years ago
many yeah I think but that's the when
your friends start to say you've changed
it's because they don't know how to say
you've grown and because they see so few
people who have so it makes sense that
they don't have that so I see that as a
lack of skill not not malice like it's
not that they're bad people they just
don't even know it because so few people
do change so few people do grow have you
seen this image it's a person whose
heart and head are flowers it's kind of
a 2d drawing it's a bit of a sketch okay
and um they say this person with the
kind of smaller flower head and heart
says you've changed and the person on
the other side with this huge Blooming
Thing says I should hope so yeah I
haven't seen it but I see it in my head
yeah it's brilliant one of my friends
George Mack told me this 5 years ago I
think think I'm astounded by how many
people want to be spectacular in life
but also want to be normal by being
normal You Are by definition aiming for
average normal people get normal results
exceptional people get exceptional
results you literally can't do what
everyone else does and expect to not get
what everyone else has got by doing what
everyone else does you guarantee average
results okay so this comes down to
everything that like business I mean
obvious I come from the business and
invest World um like if everyone is
jumping on to crypto like by the time
you have all the information to make a
perfect decision it's too late and by
the time you have consensus where
everyone's like that's a good investment
it probably isn't because it's already
been mispriced because it's already like
it's already inflated it's above what
its intrinsic value is and so like good
investors fundamentally can think for
themselves and it's such an easy thing
to say and such a hard thing to do and
so it's being able to say if I shut
myself in a room and and I had to come
up with a value for something and just
use my own mind to come up with what I
think this is worth it's that that
answer that you get in a room in
isolation with no internet connection
that you believe in that number more
than every single other person's and
most people can't do that but like that
ability and then what happens though is
if you really have to believe in that
rather than everyone else's you double
check your [__] math because if it is
different than everyone else's you have
the op you like that is what opportunity
right it's like and you have the
potential to make a shitload of money or
lose a ton of money because you didn't
check your math and so the more I've
been reinforced for thinking
independently and in the beginning it's
on small things and then you just
continue to reinforce that cycle of huh
I came to this conclusion on my own it
seems different than everyone else's but
I think I think my thing makes sense so
I'm going to do that how would you
advise someone to overcome that
regression to the mean that pull to not
make way to not be heterodox or
non-typical when it comes to their
decision making CU it's hard you're
talking about this internal conflict
versus external conflict how do you make
the internal conflict more important
than the external conflict for me I was
more miserable trying to make everyone
else happy that I am now with everyone
else unhappy with
me and so I think like from the social
group I had before I quit my job before
going all the way like Ground Zero to
today I talk to no one from that time in
my life compared to today and I was
absolutely miserable and unhappy and
unfulfilled and I would say that the
majority of those people probably don't
like me today because I changed I didn't
do what I was supposed to do he thinks
he's so fancy now etc etc and I think
I'm just okay with that and so I think
coming to terms with the idea that I
could be absolutely rejected by everyone
I
know but like me I was more okay with
that because the alternative was I
didn't want to live anymore and so
obviously there's degrees and there's
continuums and there's stages of where
people are at with that but as that
being the taken to its logical extreme
would I rather live for them than live
for me I would rather be hated by
everyone and like
myself there's a degree
of honesty is the right word but it's
also too simple like being completely
100% truthful with yourself if that's
the way that this is why have I told you
about the uh Motocross the rally cross
thing that me and my housemate love okay
so you know like Colin McCrae these guys
that drive four-wheel there's the dude
in the the co-pilot seat and it's five
left Bend all that [__] um these guys
that go to go and watch this are in the
middle of some [__] wood in Asia
right in Scotland and it's pissing wet
and it's November and they've got a pawn
show on and they get to drive for
however along to get to this PL you can
even see thinking about it the hairs on
my arms are standing up this is how
[__] dope it is so these guys are
there and they see some dude in overcast
rain freezing cold soaking wet
go and then they turn to the turn to all
of their boys and they're
like watching someone who loves anything
with that much Purity yeah fires me up
it fires me up like we love watching we
don't watch it for what the cars are
doing we watch it for what does to The
Spectators and that degree of like just
unencumbered passion yeah not being
apologetic like they've probably they're
probably wearing comfy [__] they're not
wearing cowboy boots you know what I
mean no one they they look like a like a
large condom in this pwn show do they
care right they don't care
and that's Purity yeah that's
truthfulness and and honesty and
really like what what are you hoping to
be able to to look back on your life or
for people to say after you're gone if
you don't do
that he was such a good guy and he never
rocked the boat yeah he was such a good
guy and he always conformed to our
expectations he was such a good guy and
he was so predictable right like people
think and I did throughout a lot of my
20s I thought
that what people wanted from
me was someone that they could easily
predict but I realized when I thought
about the people that I loved in my life
I didn't love them because of how
predictable they were
yeah I love them because of how
unapologetically themselves they were MH
I have a friend who
nearly ended a relationship that he's
still with who the love of his life
who's probably going to end up marrying
because he refused to not sleep on the
floor for 6 months as part of a Alex
Becker is doing it at the moment like
he's like sleeping on the floor seems to
be like a pretty dialed idea and she's
like I'm not sleeping on the floor well
I am so so they didn't sleep together
for like you know for for like a long
time yeah like that's those are the
people that you love and those are the
people that you can because they pay
such a high price to do that yeah you
can be very reliable at presuming that
they mean what they're saying mhm
because if they didn't really mean what
they're saying they would conform they
would take any e a
path I love all of
that my I was trying to kind of
consolidate it for for myself and the
listeners for me it it just it comes
down to
truly valuing your opinion of yourself
more than other people's opinion of you
and it's it's just it's an easy thing to
say and it's incredibly hard to do
because that means that if you disagree
with everyone else in the room there's
this meme that I love I don't know if
you've seen it this this little cartoon
of this one little guy and then there's
like an ocean of people that way and it
just says yes you're all
wrong and I just like I feel like that
Meme I my uh teror cashi my my uh
brother and editor in the books in the
battle against nihilism and and and
towards truth um we send that Meme back
and forth to one another when we're like
yes everyone is wrong about this word
like we are right and I think it's just
being willing to like but the only way
you can believe in a thing or an idea or
even yourself is because you have the
evidence behind you that supports that
your belief isn't full of [__] so that
when you're in that room and you come up
with that one number and you say I think
everyone's wrong I think this is
actually what it's
worth you're not just making it up to to
say you believe something different you
actually have proof and evidence that
you're not full of [__] and I think
that's the work is like I did a I looked
into a lot of the stuff on the on the
floor sleeping I think it it checks out
I'm going to do it like I think everyone
else is wrong I think everyone else is
wrong and everyone's like you're an
idiot and you're like I think you're
wrong and that's okay you know what I
and and it's just most people can't do
that just the idea of being weird is too
much like just like did you ever see did
you ever um this is quite old now it's
at least a decade old I think it's
called 50 days of rejection or 100 days
of rejection I love it already so it's a
it's a a series of experiments that you
do every day for 100 days there's a
different one each day and one of them
is ask for a free coffee when you go to
Starbucks oh I love it just say hey can
I have this for free yeah and it's I
don't know whether it escalates over
time but there's like weird stuff things
that you do to people in public things
that blah blah blah and it's trying to
overcome
that like it sort of it's in your throat
you know when you feel that and your
cheeks get flush and everything kind of
gets hot embarrassed around here yeah
it's that embarrassment it's that shame
it's that what if they think yeah what
yeah what if they think what
yeah so yeah I I someone should redo
that it's like a decade old now but
someone should redo I think I'm certain
it's called 100 days of rejection
YouTube idea that would be a great
YouTube idea to do 100 100 days of
rejection or whatever it is um all right
next one next one I I just want to like
I promise you if you can actually go
through 100 days of rejection your life
will change because you will realize
that at the end of The 100 days you're
still alive and nothing changed but it's
I'm going to die yeah that's the fear
the fear is I'm going to ask for the
coffee and they're going to say no and
then everyone's going to laugh at me and
then I'm going to be alone and then I'm
going to be unsheltered and then I'll be
dead yeah it's catastrophized to death
we all do it and so I mean obviously I
come from a sales background so getting
people to say no to me is something that
I'm now if you've asked drunken
Newcastle girls where they're going
tonight darling for a decade and a half
on the street trying to give out
wristbands for a free entry to a club
night no one wants to go to you you get
good at rejection as well
that's what I I honestly think that uh
Everyone is always going to campaign for
the thing that they did right you're
always going to say something along the
lines of I think people can learn a lot
from sales and I'm always going to say I
think people can learn a lot from being
in club promo but like honestly dude the
the Insight that you get into human
nature from doing that from seeing what
do people object to and why do they
object in that way and what happens if
someone like gets physical with you
because you tried to do and you go oh
well I wasn't in the wrong so de
escalating there should actually be
quite easy and I can have faith that
everyone's going to see me as the right
guy even if somebody else took objection
with what I was doing so yeah long story
short become a club promoter all right
next up next
one there's a big difference between
becoming known and becoming respected
don't let an algorithm convince you
otherwise I mean I think this is
probably super ptin for for people in
our position um but
I'll go from the internet perspective
and we can Circle back to IRL um but I
mean a lot of people will make content
obviously I make stuff for me too like
talk about artists making things for
themselves like I make most of my tweets
are just like notes to self um but like
if I ever feel like I have to sacrifice
who I am or the values that I believe in
in order to like get more views or
something like that I see it happen more
times than not because the algorithm and
the views and the likes become kind of a
proxy for conforming in in their own way
like Everyone likes this type of thing
do more of that and that makes me feel
very like dance monkey dance and um I
think there's there's few things that
kill my soul more than that and so I
would rather you know I would rather the
algorithm shut me off tomorrow and I
continue to make stuff that I find
interesting that 10 people find
interesting that is actually the same
stuff as me then just have these viral
hits that I feel like I'm Ronald
McDonald in um and just feel like I've
completely lost my soul and I I do think
as a side note that if you do the first
one where your intention is to maybe
help find the 10 people who are really
interested in your thing you probably
will create more of the viral hits but
when you solve for the other way I think
you accomplish
neither I have this theory that more
creators fall out of favor because they
become cringe than because they become
irrelevant I love that you yeah I love
that I think it's I think it's true I
think if you think about the thing that
you do almost anything that anybody is
creating is public facing because if it
wasn't public facing it would just be a
hobby doing your painting because you
love painting is a hobby doing your
painting to try and sell it is something
that you do as a business or as a a
public
project the flywheel is so vicious in
the positive direction and even more
vicious in the negative direction if it
becomes cancerous or uncool or untrendy
or catastrophic or cringe to be seen to
be watching or listening to or consuming
the thing that you make it is you
permanently going to be swimming
upstream and it is only going to get
worse which is why you look at Shane
Gillis is a really great example of this
at the moment he's someone who is great
at his craft big platform moved to
Austin got all of the multipliers in
place but he isn't cringe and because
he's not cringe if you've watched
beautiful dogs his Netflix special it's
not uncool it's like there's this idea
in publishing CU I've been doing my
research ahead of the book there's this
idea in publishing called the subway
test right would someone be prepared to
have the full dust jacket version of
your book out on the subway all right
and if your book is like stop erectile
this function L see the erection problem
right like yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah like like no more flatulence today
or something like if that's if that's
your book it's going to be very
difficult or if it's written by somebody
where it's like oh really don't want to
do that so and and this is the point
where there are tons and tons and tons
of people on the planet who have huge
platforms that nobody respects
mhm and I've seen even within my
seven-year career of doing this the Arc
of people trade Integrity for exposure
and not be able to buy it back yeah
because there is no return policy on
your integrity on your reputation and
those people would give anything to be
back in the Cool Kids
Club I I mean this is a like I love this
entire train
um I was thinking like what what creates
like what's what's timelessly not cringe
right like so like if cringe is the
ultimate like what we don't want then
like what would what is forever not
cringe and the only thing that I can
like really think of is is just true
authenticity which is an overused word
but
again easy to say hard to do I think
what is what is forever cringe on the
equal opposite side is is pandering like
whenever you're seen as someone who's
only doing stuff for other people's
opinion approval likes whatever
especially double cringe when it's for
your own personal gain and so if the
equal opposite of that is uh something
that is to my personal detriment um that
is truly something that I believe in it
honestly doesn't matter what it is
because there are some people that
probably believe things that I don't
believe but I genuinely think based on
what I see that they genuinely believe
it and it's and they don't really stand
to gain much for believing it yeah
there's no cringe there it's just like
that fan that man [__] believes that
and I think that um some of the you know
some of the characters in our current
you know piosphere and things like that
like many people you know you say the
word Trump and you have half the you
know people who hate you and the other
half that love you it's like I think
most people agree that he believes what
he says now whether you believe the
content of what he's saying is a
different story but Mo like I don't
think many people have called him as
somebody who's like I think he's he
doesn't really think that about himself
like no I think he I think he really
does and even I'm just going to push the
edges because that's where you have to
like explore the fringe look at someone
like Kanye who's been borderline canell
for I mean multiple times right but like
why is Kanye quote uncan because he
hasn't been right not really like if he
came out tomorrow with a hit a Hit album
I'll bet you it would [__] sell
because I think that at least for me
from what I see I think he does what he
believes and people might be like he's
mentally unstable there's all these
other but like no one thinks he's being
fake and I think that like if that
becomes the north star of like I just
never want to become cringe then it's
just never be fake in other news this
episode is brought to you by marrick
health I wanted to get my blood work
done last year and after a ton of
research I found that Mar Health has the
most sophisticated and comprehensive
service in America in fact I loved the
process so much that I reached out to
the owner to partner with them on the
show because that's how much I believe
in their service they don't just provide
you with supplements they also suggest
lifestyle interventions training diet
and everything else it really is
insanely comprehensive it's great to
feel like you have someone
professionally trained who is in your
corner helping you to understand what's
going on inside of your own body when I
started working with marrick my
testosterone was $ 495 which isn't super
low but isn't great and after 6 months
of working with them it was at 1,06 so
in less than 6 months they more than
doubled my testosterone without using
trt right now you can get the exact same
blood panel and service that I got with
a 10% discount by going to the link in
the description below or heading to Mari
health.com wisdom and the code modern
wisdom a check out that's MK health.com
modern wisdom and modern wisdom a
checkout I think
that avoiding cringe and and aligning
authenticity as best you can and it's a
permanent battle because you are not
inside of a vacuum and you see other
people doing things and there is
Temptation and you need to respond to
the audience's feedback in some regard
or else you're just going to be making
something that nobody [__] cares
about but you also need to not
compromise too much one of your old ones
related to this people are attracted to
authenticity but it's hard to Define for
me here's my best attempt true alignment
of what you think what you say and what
you do the hardest part is realizing
that our thoughts are [__] and that we
have to fix them instead of Faking the
next
two wholeheartedly agree you said
it man yeah that's dead on I've got a
I've got a really cool idea herostratic
Fame many people would rather be hated
than unknown in ancient Greece
herostratus burned down the Temple of
timus purely so that he would be
remembered nowadays we have nuisance
influences who stream themselves
committing crimes and harassing people
purely for clout herostratic
Fame yeah that's like the you gain the
world but you lose your soul kind of I
mean I I'm also the last person to judge
uh and so like if that's what you want
then by all means I don't think it's
what people want I think that they they
think it's what they want I've been
playing with this idea or this name one
of the concepts that the book will be
focused on intentionalism mhm and
essentialism Greg McAn is one of my
favorite ever books and I figured it
would be a nice like hat
nod doing what you mean to do and
wanting what you want to
want is so [__] hard to do and so
rare because we're built to
conform I think one of the my life goals
and I can summarize it in a question but
um is to be fearless and it's I mean
equal opposite C courage is another word
but I love this question which is what
would you do if you weren't afraid and I
just I love thinking about that when I'm
thinking about big life decisions like
what would I do if I weren't afraid and
it's usually like the big one the the
bigger thing that I really want to do
but I'm afraid to do it it's like that's
what I should do um and to your point
about you had the five things that you
told your team the one that we have is
um originally it was something that we
called one of one which
is make only things that we can make
like you'll never see a Coca-Cola
business breakdown from Alex rosi
because anyone can do a Coca-Cola
business breakdown that's not one of one
content but if I say I doubled the sales
of this company by implementing these
four things no one else can say that
because no one else did it right and so
it's one of one and
so as the book launch and whatnot came
um we took one of one and it became this
big massive thing and it wasn't it
stopped being about like what can only
do things that that only we can do it
was about doing things that we didn't
even know we could do yet which became
one of zero and that's why that became
the brand that I'm going to continue to
wear for the next few years um and build
that Association but I think that that
kind of encapsulates my personal life
goal which is like what would I do if I
weren't afraid and what would I do if I
didn't if I knew I couldn't fail and the
idea that I will never wish for fewer
epic stories at the end of my life and
I've never regretted failures I've
always regretted things that I didn't
try and so just along those lines of
trying to create more bias internally
towards action rather than inaction and
normalizing consequences of failure as
as we said earlier win or learn and I
think that that little frame believe it
or not um for anyone who's like on the
teetering edge of like what should I do
that thing when I was debating quitting
my job which is still the hardest
decision I've made to to this day still
of the many that I've made um was I
figured that if I didn't make the
entrepreneurship thing work I would have
a hell of a story for business school
and that was actually like the the
reasoned argument that I gave myself for
being willing to quit was that I think
that with my experience I'll still be
able to get a job and I'll have a really
cool story of Entrepreneurship that I
could use to apply to get into business
school and then eventually get a job
later and so most times we catastrophize
any failure to death right which is like
I'm going to I'm going to fail I'm going
lose on money I'm going to be homeless
no one's want to talk to me I'm going to
die right but like if you if you play it
out two natural steps like okay I lose
everything what do I do I would probably
have a couch or floor that someone would
lend me because at least socially I
haven't been I haven't [__] everyone I
know and so I have that it's like okay
so I would have some capacity to do that
okay is there anything that I could do
in the meantime in order to make money
well sure I could drive Uber and strip
and I've already you know I've told this
story before but for me that was
genuinely my plan B cuz I knew that I
could probably make 70 80 grand a year
driving Uber I could probably make 150
stripping maybe 200 strip with the gay
bars the guys pay better uh and then uh
and you know boom I've got 280,000 a
year I could live on the floor and then
I could restart again and so that's
because I don't have a lot of Shame with
that kind of stuff that's not like that
doesn't matter to me but I
think playing out the fear Lela says
this and I love it but that fear is a
mile wide and an inch deep and so it
looks like this ocean that you're going
to step into and drown but as soon as
you step into it you realize it was not
that deep at all and you can keep
walking through it and um I just love
that visual because a lot of times when
it's like we have this anxiety around
this big decision we have to make if you
actually take the step and realize that
it's not death you're not going to drown
immediately there's plenty of other
steps you can take from there even if
you get a little wet did I tell you my
story about a friend who went through a
cancellation and was worried he was a
coward oh like a like a public
cancellation thing okay so
I went for dinner quite a while ago now
with this guy that I was pretty
interested in and he knew what I did and
we went sort of bumped into each other
and what are you doing uh let's go for
dinner and I knew about the situation
that he'd been through but he didn't
know that I knew so I was like tell me
like I'm there's no pressure and he was
able to be unincumbered and basically
went through like a a tough cancellation
where kind of the whole world came down
to bear on him and he was telling me
this story I was in a very interesting
time I
like being very
reflective and he said my whole life I'd
been worried that I was a
coward was terrified that I was a
coward but I'd never been through a
situation where I'd had to bring
absolutely everything to bear on my
life and I'm a hard man and I like to
hang around with hard men and I like to
shoot guns and do Jiu-Jitsu and and and
be around Navy Seals and stuff like that
but I always had this fear in the back
of my mind that I might secretly be a
coward and then he said the cancellation
thing happened and it wasn't a very
difficult one rep max it wasn't a really
hard crossfit workout it was something
outside of his
control he used this term that I love
and he said uh I could always hear my
better self clearing his throat in the
room next
door and I always wondered what would
happen if I had to really really Wrangle
everything if the whole world Came
Crashing Down on
Me and I wanted to work out whether or
not I was a coward and he
said thankfully he kicked the door in
and came through but I just love that I
could always hear my better self
clearing his throat in the room next
door but he' never been fully tested
done lots of hard things lot of ACC
claim very successful blah blah blah but
we all know that's your thing right like
but I'll know about whether or not
you've left something on the table and
uh
yeah he there was always just 5% still
in the tank when he was doing things
about how he felt about how invested he
was he always had to get out of jail
free card in one way or another and uh
yeah I love that I [__] I could
always hear my better self clearing his
throat in the room next
door two things on that so I think if
we're if we're consoling some of the
points we were making earlier the but
I'll know
refrain I think that a lot of the
personal Excellence comes down to making
the but I'll know more important than
the but everyone what will everyone else
think because the I think the true test
of whether you're a quote perfectionist
or not is if everyone else in the room
says it's exceptional and then you
say but I'll know it's not because I
don't think it's exceptional yet if you
still break what everyone else believes
is beautiful so that you can make the
thing that you make it the way you want
it to make or make it the way you want
it to be I think that is probably like
the the truest test of whether or not
you really do value your own opinion
over those of other people's and if you
really want to be true to quote the art
whatever your art is AR I'm using it as
a generic term it could be the career or
the even like the ex the the financial
projection that you're supposed to do at
your company like there is a way you
could do it and do it absolutely [__]
excellent and there's a way you could do
it that you could phone it in and
probably not get in trouble but the
things that you'd know and then you'd be
the type of person who always phones it
in and that to me is disgusting and that
would make me disgusted with me and that
is the thing that would make me want to
peel my skin off because I would hate me
and I think that's why so many people do
hate them because they do settle and
they do make these things and they do
know and still ignore it and so they
ignore the man in the other room who's
clearing his throat and they shut the
door and they lock it and they never let
that guy in and so they look like
everyone else they act like everyone
else and they get what everyone else
gets America was built on the backs of
men who smoked cigarettes drove without
seat belts and had bacon for breakfast
if you miss your biohacking routine this
morning you're going to be okay there's
a time for leverage but there's also a
time for violence which is just brute
force people get really obsessed with
optimal which is getting the most bang
for your book but there's also
maximizing which is just getting the
most bucks you lose more life trying to
optimize everything than just living it
the stress of trying to be perfect is
killing you more quickly than your
imperfections
I think that's an Ode
to beinging being willing to take huge
amounts of imperfect
action towards one goal and being
willing to sacrifice other
things for an extended period of time
despite the fact that other people say
they're making a sacrifice like when we
enter Seasons I call it you know the
season of no which is where you have I
have extended duration where I say no to
almost everything and most people say
that's unbalanced and they hurl that as
though it's a bad thing they're like
that's so unbalanced you're like yes
that's the point because if I had a
balanced outcome then I won't have the
outsized return on this one thing and so
again like there's so many these little
insults that people will throw at you
like you're unbalanced you changed you
that they intend as insults but if you
actually don't take your Society
programmed response and say oh they mean
to insult me but if you actually think
about what they're saying they're saying
something that's true and then we just
need to be okay with that truth because
that was the choice we made to begin
with and so I think about that a lot
which is like how many things do people
tell me that they intend to insult me
with that I can take as a
compliment didn't someone bump into
Leila walking down the street yeah it
was it happened so recently so yeah
we're walking in the street someone
bumps into her I like we don't always
walk like side by side cuz there's lots
of people so we like split up sometimes
anyways she she comes back to me and she
was like guess what this guy just said
and I was like what and she was like he
called me a skinny [__] and I was like
what and she but she seemed so happy and
I was like and I was like like I just
kind of shook my head like tell me more
like explain she was like I mean he said
I was
skinny and I was like this is the this
is the perfect example of him hurling an
insult and her choosing not to be
insulted thank you yeah thanks but
really yeah do you really mean
it it it like there like I wonder how
many times we've been insulted even like
in my younger days where someone said
something to me that like if I had my
current brain I could have been like you
you really mean it thanks
man and um yeah like so unbalanced I me
remember I remember I took that as such
an insult for such a long period of time
now part of that was because when I I
was being brought up balance was like
one of the big frames of my household
was like you have to be balanced which
really just meant you have to be awesome
at everything thing um but balance was
the was the word so being unbalanced was
was a term that was used as an insult
and so um for so many years I wanted to
be balanced um but then I was like well
nothing great was ever achieved by
people who tried to be great at all
things and so I was like okay I'm just
not going to I'm not I might not have a
great relationship for a long period of
time I mean there was like a lot of
people don't know this but in the early
days of our Rel of our relationship um
even when we were married I told Le so
the first 3 years um I said the business
comes before our marriage so a lot of
people don't know that um and I was like
well to me it made sense it was like
most people break up over money the
business makes money so the business
feeds us and then we will be okay that
was kind of my my thinking around it um
and we eventually flipped that said like
if we're good the business will be fine
uh but took three years to get there um
but all that to say
like I think having periods of imbalance
and maybe to be fair if we if I hadn't
had that that priority at that time
maybe gym launch wouldn't have been what
it became and so I can't look back and
say like I should have done it different
because it's really easy to say that now
but like I might not be here to say that
if I had been that way Oliver burkman's
got this Great Frame where he talks
about choose in advance what you're
going to suck at oh yeah it's in 4,000
weeks and if you are a type a go-getter
person who has what I called the curse
of competence your options in life are
restricted more by what you choose than
what you can do mhm
you will feel dis Qui when something
that you used to be great at begins to
slip because you focused your attention
elsewhere you used to be in really great
shape you said that one of your goals
this year was to get a raise or to be
able to buy your first house or to find
a partner or to do whatever hey guess
what if you're spending four or five
nights a week going to places where you
can maybe date or going out on dates or
doing whatever you're probably not going
to have as much time to dedicate to the
gym if if you want to get that raise or
be able to save for your first house or
whatever you're going to have to work
later which maybe means that your
friends are going to drop off if you
pick whatever the thing is there is a
price that you begin to pay and this
cycle began for me so frequently toward
the back end of my 20s where I would
dedicate myself to a thing then
something else would begin to slip so I
would then go oh I'll just I'll I'll
just give a little bit I'll just give a
little bit to that and it's not an
additive system it's multiplicative it's
not 2 plus like three it's 2 time three
and that means that the more that you
attend to the thing that you say that
you're going to
do the more the gains ACR to you and
then you can still pivot back but you
need to periodize things and this is
this is a frame that I wish even now
it's it's still something that I
struggle with realizing that now isn't
forever the thing that you're doing
right now doesn't need to be forever
yeah if you are coming out the back of
of the searching for the partner thing
and you're like hey guess what I gained
15 all right well dedicate yourself for
the next 6 months to going to the gym
but this isn't the rest of your life
right and once that thing's done oh well
guess what I'm back to you know 12% body
fat I feel great about myself what's
next it's not forever yeah it's just for
now yes we have a frame that we actually
use a lot um I I've I always think about
these things from a business context but
they end up retroactively you know
applying to life um but when we're
making big strategic decision
we say like which problems would we
prefer and so rather than talking about
like the gains and what's the upside if
we have like you know let's say we're
going to make a big investment in
software for this company or we're going
to make a big you know huge a new
service line or we're going to just
decide to develop a physical product
right I mean I know you you're L like
you're literally on the just back half
of of a big decision like this yourself
it's like okay let's imagine what the
problems are going to be if we if we
decide to do this new service category
well some people are going to complain
that they're not getting results from
this thing uh we're going to have a ton
of like we might have some negative
reviews in the short term that we're
going to have to deal with like let's
look at what happens when one of our
favorite customers tell us the [__] off
like what like like let's really sit in
what each of these problems is and then
when we when we spell out all of the
problems and we don't even think about
the upside say which of these problems
do we prefer and which Are we more
equipped to deal with sometimes we have
really amazing Innovation and in my
opinion like really solid decision-
making that comes afterwards that
minimizes kind of the the post-decision
regret because we also know what
negatives would have come with the path
unchosen because most most times like
our regrets from Come From the Path and
chosen because we imagine it only with
the upside we only think about I think
there's a um there's a [__] there's a
book that where a girl lives many
different versions of her life and
Midnight Library yes and the thing is is
that there's these pieces of her life
that she imagines are going to be
amazing but then she realizes her best
friend's dead or all of a sudden she's
pregnant and you're like whoa what
happened and so we don't take into
account on the paths not taken the
things that we would have lost along the
way and so I think really good decision-
making and also regret minimization is
that when you make the decision you
think about the downsides too and you
remember what those downsides are and
for me that has been one of my strongest
frames for like I didn't decide to do
that were all that oh yeah those were a
lot I'm glad I those are problems I'm
very happy I don't have to deal with now
in other news this episode is brought to
you by nomatic you might have seen that
I recently was on the Road for a full 28
days using just hand luggage because
hold luggage is a scop meant to keep you
poor and late and almost everything is
down to this backpack and the carry-on
that I was using this is their travel
pack their 20 L travel pack and honestly
it is the best backpack that I've ever
found it would take way longer than I've
got to explain all of the different
pieces of tech that are inside of this
but it basically allows you to pack so
much more stuff with so much less fuss
and it's outstanding they're beautifully
designed not over engineered and has a
life lifetime guarantee so this is
literally the final backpack that you
will ever need to buy also you can
return or exchange your bag for any
reason within 30 days so you can buy it
try it use it and carry stuff in it for
a full month and if you don't like it
they'll give you your money back head to
the link in the show notes below or go
to nomatic docomo wisdom use the code
modern wisdom at checkout for a 20%
discount off everything sitewide that's
Nom matic.com
wisdom and modern wisdom a
checkout thinking about the Perils of
over optimization is something I brought
up with huberman last year and you know
I think a lot of people I have a friend
who's a very well-known DJ that told me
he was falling out of love with dejing
because he knew that it was damaging his
sleep and because he knew how important
sleep was to Performance that he' kind
of got him the bar stool had been turned
upside down a little bit and the thing
that he was trying to do was being
sacrificed for the thing which is
supposed to facilitate it mhm and that's
where the you lose more life trying to
optimize everything than just living it
the stress of trying to be perfect is
killing you more quickly than your
imperfections all right so I I I'm glad
we came back to optimization because um
there's obviously on the extreme there's
uh guys like Brian Johnson with
blueprint who are trying to like live to
200 or live forever um and I I I respect
the I respect dedication to anything
always um and interestingly around I've
always been a maxim so I've actually not
really been an Optimizer in my life it's
just like as soon as I have an input
output equation where it's like n equals
X and it's like and if I want 10x I do
10 n I'm like great then can we do a th
n like I just want to do as much of that
as I humanly possible um but when we
like I love competitors who like
optimizing because I always see it as a
weakness because it's so easy to exploit
it's like oh you need your eight hours
of sleep or you need your morning
routine or you if you don't have your
supplements you're just totally [__]
or like I didn't have my coffee this
morning so I can't function like I love
to compete against people like that
because they're so easy to break it's
fragile yeah and so what happens is the
optimizations become Superstition
correct and so my my fear around and I
and maybe I take a more extreme stance
on this but like I've always wanted
to be able to with an internet
connection and a laptop and a foldout
chair go make money and always have that
as my star that anything else is extra
and I feel like I lose
more quickly when I get into this
optimization cycle around because I
remember years ago I um I bought one of
those rings that tracks your sleep and I
kept trying to like set sleep PRS and
you can only get so high anyways and
then I started stressing more about not
hitting sleep PRS that I was sleeping
worse than when I wasn't tracking it and
so then I was like well [__] this thing
and I slept fine the next night and so
um obviously microcosm I'm a big
believer in tracking progress in general
but just the idea that we become so
overly romantic around these things that
sometimes you just have to break [__]
and sometimes you have to be violent and
sometimes when you're on your journey
you're not going to sleep much and
you're going to you're going to like
there was a a two-year period where I
did uh turnarounds for gyms I flew
around the nation every month I would do
a new gym I ate out of gas stations and
I ate gas Station food and I gained
weight during that period of time and it
was for then and not forever and I'm in
shape now and so whatever who cares and
so like I used to tell this when I was
selling weight loss to people I'd say
like who cares if you get in shape for 6
weeks out of 80
years and like right as they're about to
sign up for a membership I was like you
want to and then this is how I would
sell longer memberships but like it's
also true it's like you want to sign up
for the six weeks but like
Susan like who cares if you lose 20 lbs
and you're still overweight 6 weeks from
now and then you gain it back the next 6
weeks and you're still the exact same
weight for the rest of your life and so
I just I think the absolute dedication
to maximization so that becomes a part
of your identity and your character has
been one of the outsid returns that I've
gotten in my life and just being
absolutely willing to S like I'm I'm
pretty violent about this but
like list all the things that you aren't
willing to give up for the dreams that
you have and that is what the person who
will beat you is willing to give up
there's a phenomenal blog post that
talks
about why guys aren't getting
girlfriends and this is premodern mating
crisis so it's not it's not to do with
like imbalances on Tinder and tall girl
problem and all that all that stuff it's
a a guy who thinks that the bare minimum
is acceptable so he talks about how I'm
always on time and and you know I hold
the door open and I say please and thank
you and I'm nice to my mom and the dude
I'll never forget it there's this line
in in the blog post where the guy who's
like having this pretend dialogue with
this imaginary person goes so [__]
what there's a guy who does all of those
things and he plays the
guitar well it's like the the song lyric
uh baby you the whole package and you
pay your taxes um yeah I mean I think
also to the same degree I mean like I'm
I'm no mating whatever expert like no
idea I got married early did all the
things that you know whatever you're not
supposed to do um yeah and
yet if you like if you are true to you
like what's the most unring thing right
is you being
you I'm pretty sure that I turned away
plenty of girls so were like this guy's
successful he's in shape uh you know
decent looking strikingly handsome um
but they'd meet me and they'd be like
what a [__]
weirdo but the thing is is like they
like and I remember I had um there were
so many girls that I was like you're
pretty and I I I just don't care at
[Laughter]
all and so I like I just I wanted
someone who got my peculiarities who was
like not only like accepting of them but
just like down for it and so i' I walked
through most of my and to be fair as a
side note for anybody who like wants to
quote be exceptional you're going to be
different and people are going to think
you're weird and like you might not get
second dates but real real you're not
going to want the second date to because
they're not like you like when you get
unplugged you're like oh wow everyone's
a sheep this is weird and you just go on
a zillion First Dates to be like yet
another one yet another one and every
once in a while you see a glimmer in
someone who they're like oh you think
for yourself like you can make your own
conclusions I remember when Leela and I
went on our first date we were we were
we went at a at a frozen yogurt store
and so of course I'm like so you know
how they make their money here right I
was like so these things weigh this they
charge this per ounce and I was like
breaking this whole thing down and she
was like oh yeah and they do this and
this and I was like wait you see this
too like you it wasn't like just like
Alex just talking about the child out of
the [__] six sense or whatever it is
I was so excited because normally I
would just have to like talk I would
talk about the stuff that at least I
like to talk about because then we' pass
the not good dating strategy I'm want to
myself yeah but then she also like talk
about this stuff and I was like holy
[__] what's the alternative the
alternative is to find someone who falls
in love with a role that you're playing
right that's the best that you can hope
for right and then lock yourself in to a
future of having to perform in a way
that this person has become accustomed
to and there's nothing that can be more
lonely than I can possibly imagine then
pretending every single hour of every
day that you're someone you're not do
you know who Dr Robert Glover is No More
Mr Nice Guy no but I like the title had
him on the podcast last week this guy is
a [__] boss so cool like mid-60s or
something now huge goatee smoke
cigarettes uh probably probably rip
starts that by this this office by the
way is completely it's like smoking
enabled we're in Vegas um and he had
three Essences of an attractive man and
I think it's a really lovely frame the
essence of an attractive man he's
comfortable in his own skin he knows
where he's going and he has fun while
he's going
there
nailed nailed so good so good but like
that if you think about that as okay so
if if if if you're and like even like an
attractive man whether you're married or
not like I mean on the flip side it's
like do you want to be married and then
choose to become unattractive well no of
course not and so it's like if those are
three ideals it's like you have you have
Direction in your life you're internally
comfortable and the fun part is what
makes you I mean partially attractive
now mind you if you just have one of the
three you can you will find a mate who's
attract like if you just know with all
your [__] soul you're going somewhere
people will want to Rally behind you
even if you're not having fun and even
if you're not got 10 kids right and even
if you're not that comfortable in your
own skin but you're like that guy like
no matter what he's going to [__] get
there on the flip side if you don't know
where you're going and you don't even
have much fun but you're like that guy
is comfortable like say what you want
but that guy is good with him that's an
like that Al like if you just had one
and if you just have a shitload of fun
you don't know where you're going and
you're not that comfortable like you'll
still have people um I'd probably prefer
the first two to the third but
you know but like as ideals like [__]
very
strong the only insults that hurt are
the ones we believe next time someone
insults you remember they're going to
die everyone will forget about them and
if no one will remember them then you
might as well forget about them now they
are irrelevant your dream your actions
your outcomes so now you know what the
inside of my head looks like
um um I mean I I uh I put almost
everything immediately to death um and
that's like maybe it's a coping
mechanism maybe it's a perspective
mechanism um but like you want to hear I
I was really strongly considering having
a parody um tweet profile of my own that
I also run that no one would know that I
run that is just like all my very very
controversial beliefs um but I'll I'll
I'll throw a taster out now
um murder is just picking when someone
dies so it's like if you hate someone
it's like you can just look at them be
like oh you're going to die
eventually like and so like the idea is
like in your mind you could murder every
enemy you have you just just don't get
to pick the time but I just find that so
such a like murder only changes when not
that someone's going to die and so if
you think about like retribution on
someone it's like this person said this
thing to me H I want to kill him it's
like oh no you don't even have to
they'll die they're going to die already
like you don't even have like don't
worry about it they're going to die and
so it sounds so silly but just
connecting those two dots I was like wow
that's incredibly peaceg giving so like
why have a vendetta when life will take
care of them for me uh and so I just
like you know as a as a as a totally
different frame I was talking to
somebody who has cancer uh in my life
and uh they were like really concerned
they were like this has uh has a 95%
mortality rate over the next five years
and um you know me being me I was like
well you know 70 year olds probably have
a 60% mortality rate over the next five
years anyways I was like and life has
100% mortality rate so you know worse
yes but like how much worse and So like
um they didn't think it was funny
but but just as a as a it it was
intended to be comforting it didn't
succeed um but uh all that to say uh
these these things that people cast on
us um
it
just Whispers In The Wind right like if
we think that our whole meaning is is so
infantes the idea that someone else can
influence our trajectory when they
themselves will disappear and become
irrelevant seems so silly to me and they
don't have our best interest at heart no
they have the opposite of our best
interest yeah they're literally trying
to destroy you what about the only
insults that hurt are the ones we
believe what about that oh yeah um well
I cuz I like other people get Ed with
things and then I've also had times
where someone says something with the
intention to insult and it doesn't and I
was like how can I get that to happen
every time and so it's the classic
example of you know Chris you have green
hair and then you would say okay
whatever sure but you don't believe it
so it doesn't really matter and so I
think there's there's a there's kind of
a dual-sided like lesson at least for me
in this is that when we are
insulted I try and pay attention to it
because I think okay either there's
something here that they're right about
and that I don't like about myself in
which case the response is to
agree and that's what's so frightening
and so it's like if someone so recently
had someone someone made some thing
blasting me about um I don't go home for
the holidays I made this whole I made
this video about it um and in the first
5 Seconds of the video of course I'm
like if you love your family [__] go
home this is not this is for everybody
else right but of course no one actually
watches that who makes that piece of
content and so they just went on this
tie rate about me and I just said
God I suck period as my comment and
because there's no the the the the stoic
response to hate is to agree and one up
so level one is agree so someone says
Alex you're a [__] idiot and you're
like believe me if you knew half of it
you'd think more than that because it's
the only way you can respond and so my
mental Judo for these things and I've
just I try to now the good news for you
and I is that we get lots of practice
right every day we have people hating on
us and so I get to I get to pract so
like people people meet you in real life
and they they trying to insult you
you're like dude I have so many reps on
this like oh good and so it's just like
can I want up their insult like if
someone insults me it's like dude let me
I dude you think that's good let me tell
you how to really get me right and so
just the frame of agreement evaporates
conflict yeah that's your thing about um
most people are more interested in
winning than being right yeah so you
just say sure you're right yeah Alex
you're an idiot all of your business
advice is terrible be like you're
right now what Where Do We Go From Here
Right wasn't that
fun and so we talk like because like I
like it human behavior a lot but like
it's called it's it's a it's a
extinguishing event so like when you
when you when you pull a slot machine
when when null is the outcome it
nullifies agreement is the ultimate
nullifier for
insults and I I think that like if the
the faster I I reprogram that so it's
like if you ever feel insulted either
like first is it is it true like if you
are insulted you believe them okay uh do
I believe them because there's an
element of truth if there's an element
of Truth why am I insulting I should
agree with them it's just because we
have some ego behind it of like I I'm
going to be perceived a certain way or
maybe because it's poking a hole it's
wedging into the inauthenticity that
someone has brought into the light
something which we thought we were able
to keep in private one of my other life
goals is to die with no
secrets why just
be because if we think about at least
for me if I think about authenticity um
to be seen as I truly am then I would
have no secrets and I try you know I try
really hard uh to not hold anything back
content or otherwise um so that I don't
need to have I don't want to have a
hundred faces because if you always have
something in the back room that it means
that to these people you're this person
and this is in the back room to these
people you're this person in the back
room but the fewer back rooms I have the
more everyone is in one room and I can
be just me and that means that some
people will hate me um and some people
will like me but they will actually like
or hate me not the idea or some facet
like we were saying earlier that when
you're in a relationship putting on the
ACT and putting being the performer
they're not hating the idea of me they
actually hate me and at least there's
some weirdness about like at least
that's true in other news this episode
is brought to you by Shopify Shopify is
the global Commerce platform that helps
you sell at every stage of your business
from the launch your online shop phase
to the first real life store stage to
the did we just hit a million orders
stage Shopify can support you every step
of the way from that all-in-one
e-commerce platform to that in-person
POS system whatever you're selling and
wherever you're selling it Shopify has
got you covered Shopify helps you turn
browsers into buyers with the internet's
best converting checkout 36% better on
average compared to other leading
e-commerce platforms Shopify Powers 10%
of all e-commerce in the United States
including huge Brands like gym shark and
my brand newtonic we literally launch
newtonic on Shopify because it's the
best platform for e-commerce so if you
want to start selling without learning
to code or Design This is where to start
right now you can sign up for a $1 per
month trial period by going to the link
in the show notes below or heading to
shopify.com
mowis all lower case that's shopify.com
wisdom to grow your business now no
matter what stage you're in there's a a
lesson that I learned from Rob Henderson
which is like an interesting addition to
what we're talking about here and he
asked the
question why do we feel insulted or why
do our cheeks flush when somebody
accuses us of something that we know
that we haven't done and the issue here
is that we don't exist in a vacuum and
we care about other people's
interpretations of us and a
disinformation campaign even if it's
grounded in falsehood can still
negatively impact us status mhm so even
if you know that this isn't true and all
of the rest of it functionally to
everybody that isn't you or maybe many
people that aren't you or maybe some
people who are influential that aren't
you this can have the same impact as if
it was true yeah so
that the man being an island and I have
faith in my own word yeah as soon as you
start to build this out it's there's a
reason for trepidation there mhm I think
so I was trying to think about like the
what are what are counter examples so
like if someone attacks your character
right so let's say uh someone comes out
and says Alex did some sort of sexual
allegation or something like that that I
know isn't true whatever but they say
that now that's going to bch my
reputation right now I can't be like
you're right and if you really knew
right like right so I
can't if you knew the half of it um so
like so like those those are the
situations right so so like if someone
just says like you're you know you're
full of [__] or your business advice is
bad or whatever then that's one thing um
but in those situations um the only
counter that I have seen is
to be
louder and so if someone increases the
volume on something I don't believe that
you draw attention to that person I
actually I've more or less not been in
the I'm going to address someone
directly but I make counter what this
person says without addressing them and
be 10 times bigger and louder about it
as a way to counteract that and so like
I had a bad reputation in college which
I i' I've shared some of that in my
story before um and the reputation was
that I was a philanderer and was you
know all about girls and whatever and so
I wanted to not have the reputation and
so it wasn't like I was going to go talk
to those girls and be like I need you to
recant your story um I had to make my
actions so much louder that I was no
longer going to be that way for an
extended period of time to counteract
that thing and so if we're thinking
about like how to respond to people
being shitty to you if you believe what
they say and it's true agree and one up
if what they say is something that isn't
true but does bmer your reputation then
you can only be respond by being louder
with the truth and I think that like I I
think about these things obviously we're
in a position we have to deal with this
all the time um as like almost playbooks
for dealing with
shots well this is one of the things
that people got wrong about Dave
portnoy's cancellation so I didn't even
know he got canceled Dave had sex with
maybe two two or three girls that sold
the story no separately okay sold a
story to the Atlantic I think yeah [__]
num um sold sold a story to someone and
they were they were looking around and I
think they're still going I'm pretty
sure that only a couple of months ago
they tried to notify some pizza event
that he was doing do you know that we're
investigating him about that and then he
called them out
so what's happened is there's been
million me to allegation things that
have come across people saw the way that
Dave pno responded he came out of the
fences absolutely swinging like swinging
so hard said this is [__] bollocks
it's baseless I think he maybe even
somehow had video evidence or or audio
evidence or some kind maybe internal
CCTV cameras basically all of stuff is
dog [__] yeah people took Dave pnoy
didn't take any [__] and and and he
didn't back down and he didn't do an
apology and he didn't do the rest it's
like yeah guess
why because he didn't do it right
because he wasn't in the wrong yeah if
you are the guy that did do the thing
yeah you don't have that that's a firm
foundation what you're doing there is
just creating this like Cathedral of of
lies and dog [__] on top of a sand
castle of lies and dog [__] which will
then get found out and you get hit you
get slam 10 times way way way harder
yeah rightfully so to be fair you'll get
that's the thing so learning okay why
did he do this particular tactic well he
ran that play yeah because the basis of
where he was at allowed him to loud as
[__] about the truth one one thing that
we talked about earlier with cancelling
and I have um so relatively contrarian
views on cancelling um I genuinely
believe that you cannot be canceled you
only are you can only be canceled in two
ways you can be canceled if you choose
to stop making content stop being public
or all means and methods and channels of
communication that you do not control
remove you from it so like for example
uh there's Tate right and he had his uh
like he's not allowed to be on the
platforms but they allow his content be
on the platform so has he been cancelled
no I would argue not and there's still
other platforms and he continues to make
content so you only so I to me this is
actually really um uh kind a
heartwarming uh security feeling I I get
warm and fuzzies around it reassuring
thank you um because it means that
cancellation is you have to agree to be
canel no matter how bad like if you mess
platform one yeah a yeah if they if they
L if they had AI face recognizing him
and and eliminated from the platform he
would be canceled like there's no method
of communication outside of in person he
would have no leverage
agreed but barring that if you continue
to make content no matter what you did
people will find out about you more
people will know about you and your
message will get disseminated and
whether you choose to like recant
something that you did you know like
right or wrong apologize or do what Dave
did and say like this is complete
bollocks he's my little UK term uh and
just be even
louder you choose to be canceled and I I
like that because I I like to have as
many things under my control as I
can yeah the i' I've been like thinking
about the stri and effect because
everyone's always said you know
cancellation makes people bigger I think
that is cope I think it's massive cope I
don't think that cancellation makes
people bigger Alex Jones for instance
when he got he got about as close to
unpersoned I think as you can get very
very I wasn't seeing for the last
whatever five years eight years whenever
he got taken off Twitter I wasn't seeing
him on YouTube unless he was on somebody
else's show uh I wasn't seeing him on
Instagram I wasn't seeing him on Twitter
Steve will do it as a good example as
well like he can't even be in the
background of other people's YouTube
videos and he's got shares in Rumble and
he's doing all of this other stuff but
still that's a pretty big unperson and I
think it's kind of cope to say oh but so
many more people are searching them like
the entire internet is built on
convenience yeah if you think that
making it more inconvenient for someone
to access someone makes them bigger you
are fundamentally forgetting Human
Nature now maybe in this you know
beautifully utilitarian rational view of
the world the person that wants to see
the thing they might go and get the
thing but it's like hey guess what like
Tik tok's got an unlimited scroll yeah
and they're just going to keep going and
if they don't appear they don't appear
and to draw this into IRL for everyone
who's like okay well that might be
convenient for Alex Jones and whatnot
like he can't or he can or can't be
canceled whatever I think that at least
for me the through line on this is like
if you do some embarrassing thing which
happens we're human the only way it
compounds into being like a much bigger
problem is if you become a recluse you
choose to not go out you choose to not
you choose to disassociate with everyone
else like you choose to agree to the
terms that the people around you are
telling you you have to agree to and
that's where I think you can say no
Destiny's got this idea he told me this
story I think it was like VidCon or
vidsummit 2012 and Destiny's sprayed it
around a bit in his career and he was at
this huge YouTuber convention and his
ex-girlfriend or something got access to
his Twitter account and leaked his
dickpics on his Twitter while he's at
this vidsummit thing surrounded by his
peers so he's trending so it's not only
oh my god look what's happening on the
Internet it's oh my God the internet has
now become real life and it's in front
of me and there's thousands and
thousands of people and they all know
what's going on and you know Finding
Nemo just keep swimming just keep
swimming from Dory his is just keeps
streaming he says everybody only
remembers your last four streams yeah so
sure enough you went on first stream
just the chat is lit up taking the piss
out of him and oh like here it is second
second one still lots and lots and lots
of jokes third one uh like a few less
then fourth one was pretty much gone
yeah after four stream it's not funnym
we've all heard it yeah so true Jordie
got um he's like a British UK uh
YouTuber big guy and um a few years ago
his DMS got leaked from his verified
Instagram account saying some like
pretty dirty sex stuff to a girl and
she was of age she was of age yeah there
was no it was like it was kind of I
guess it was intimate it was intimate
and like embarrassing or whatever for
him but he uh he was silent pretty much
silent for 5 days and then got probably
the best roast comedian in the UK to
come on and annihilate him yeah
for 20 minutes in a video and put it out
on his own YouTube channel and it's that
B rabbit thing tell these people
something that they don't already know
about me like what joke are you going to
make that Steven Tes like literally the
most vicious funny sardonic UK roast
person hasn't already said and it showed
that he could laugh at himself dude this
is the uh so this is the take what they
say oneup them right and so like I'm
going to take what they say find a
person who is professional at one-upping
them and then bring them in and then
publish it to your million person
YouTube channel yes like we um we so we
actually teach this from a customer ser
I know I'm going totally across pilot
Nation here but we call there's there
can only be one person in the angry boat
and so customer comes in they're
shouting and I learned this from my like
ear one of my earliest business mentors
I worked at a fur coat dealer uh so like
brushing you know Furs it's a glorious
job um I was 18 it was a summer and so
this lady walks in and I was at the the
retail shop which normally I was in the
warehouse where the The Peasants were
and uh and so this lady comes in and
she's making a whole mess of noise and
the guy walks towards me cu the owner
and I see like roll his eyes and then as
he turns turns the corner to go where
she can see him he like his face turns
into a smile and then he's like he's
like Miss Robinson and then he just goes
into rage mode and I was like whoa
what's happening and he was like wait
there was a button missing on your
jacket he's like give me that jacket he
like pulls it out he's like who sold
this to you who let you walk he said did
anyone see you in this and and he was
like tell me their names right now I'm
going to get the they're going to be out
of here like we're going to end like
we're going to get terminate their
employment we're going to make sure that
they never eat again all the stuff
whatever and she all of a sudden she
back she was like oh no no you know it
no one saw me in it I just got I just
saw it when I got home if you guys could
just of course we're going to fix it of
like no question whatsoever and so of
course she he takes the ticket she
leaves he comes in the back and he just
looked at me and he was like only one
person can be in the angry
boat and I and it was a lesson that has
stuck with me in like and so in this in
this instance everyone is angry at you
and so the only thing you cuz people are
contrarian by Nature all you can do is
be angrier than them at whatever it is
and so like getting the comedian to like
oh you think he insulted me like here's
a picture of my cold shrivel dick after
a nice cold after my Polar Plunge you
want to see like so it's just it's like
can you do that and it's just leaning
into what feels unnatural and
uncomfortable but it's the only way to
respond you cannot wish for a strong
character and an easy life each is the
price of the other what if what you're
going through isn't hard what if you're
just s
sensitive I think that most of us can
look back on our lives to 10 years ago
and think about the problems that we
were dealing with then and think about
how much of a pittance and how small
those problems were compared to the
problems that we deal with today at
least that's how I probably feel maybe
you feel the same
way and so I then think okay well if I
feel that way about the problems that I
had 10 years ago then 10 years from now
Alex will look back at the problems that
I'm dealing with today and feel the same
way and so if he feels that way then
about the problems that I have now then
the only difference is the perspective
that he has that I don't have and so I
might just be a sensitive little pansy
and maybe these aren't problems at all
maybe these are just Facts of Life and I
need to habituate to them because I
remember um my first lawsuit right
because it's like when you're in
business long enough you make enough
money you're just going to get suit it
is what it is and I was listening to um
Elon mus talk about this and at any
given time Tesla has hundreds of
lawsuits at any like just they they have
they have massive Departments of legal
just for all the different things that
are going on and it was thinking that a
requisite for success is a problem like
you cannot become the wealthiest man in
the world and not get sued like getting
sued is a is an indicator that you're
actually is a is a requisite for being
there there's no no person has been
there without this and so reframing what
I used to consider a problem as a as a
point of evidence that I am on the path
that I originally
chose I remember the first time that I
ever tried to Incline chest press 20
kilos and as I got it up this in the
center for sporting excellence in
Newcastle gym and as I got it up there I
didn't have the tricep strength to be
able to keep it and I watched this thing
slowly come down to my and it just
landed on my nose and I like sort of
bailed it bailed it out off my nose yeah
and and now it's not even it's not even
the warmup to the warmup to the warmup
set so the problem is that we don't
have very good memory we don't have
theory of mind for ourselves for a
previous version of ourselves I've
always thought that it would be such an
amazing talk maybe neuralink can do it
some point in future you know how people
want to go back in time and they want to
see a different place I would love to go
back in time in my own mind mhm and
remember the texture of my own existence
and what were the things that I thought
about I've told this story before but
it's pretty
illustrative day one is a journal that
you can use for your phone it's pretty
good and for me it's big [__] it's like
big things are happening if I open day
one some some [__] shit's going down
um
and breakups and and and illnesses and
and being worried about people dying or
whatever the whatever the [__] I once
opened it to write down that the
MC in room 2 the R&B room room of our
Saturday night club night had told me
that he was leaving to go to a
competitor event 15 miles away and I
remember thinking that it was so Salient
to me that it deserved to go in along
with breakups and and do I go on this
reality TV show or do I not because I
was adamant that that would be the
beginning of the end because the only
reason the Asian sock the Asian Society
came down was because they like this
particular MC and if he went then Asian
sock would stop coming and if Asian stop
stop coming then that would mean this
and then and then the whole business
would go and I'd be dead
but I don't think that anymore and there
was one there was one time where I
hadn't worked our events for quite a
while and a DJ that used to work for us
came through and he thought that he'd
wind me up by saying 3 minutes before we
opened that something was up with one of
the cdjs something's up with one of the
cdjs a couple of minutes before you open
things are bad because there's usually
not a spare and it means that the
night's going to be delayed or whatever
and there was lots of people outside
waiting to come in or whatever it might
be and he was expecting a response on
from a previous version of me which
would have been the one that would have
gone into day one and typed about the
fact that the CDJ hadn't worked and I
just
said oh okay well uh I don't know we'll
fix it and he called out broke the
fourth wall and said oh I like it's not
broken at all like I just thought that
I'd wind you up but you didn't play the
game I'm like oh right it's the like
you've grown or you've changed thing
yeah he was Juke the don't don't punk
the game yes don't punk the game yeah I
think the point is to always Punk the
game as many times as you possibly can
especially if you're the one getting the
game played on you by
yourself what's your framework for
quitting things and moving onto
something new how do you know when
you're quitting because you're being a
[__] yeah and how do you know that
you're moving on from something that's
no longer
worthwhile man so there's a there's a
handful of questions that I think
everyone faces that um you never know
the right answer to and so it's like how
much is the right amount to invest
versus consume is one of those answers
like if you invest if you consume
nothing and you invest everything into
it to tomorrow you end up with a life
where you enjoyed nothing and then you
have a big pile of delayed gratification
in the extreme results and no
gratification right and so like there
these are these are rather than either
ores they're continuums and so to be
managed more than uh problems to be
solved and so I think just from a a
decision-making framework that's number
one um number two is so with regard this
one which is do you push or do you pivot
which is how I I frame this question um
pushing like do I push through whatever
this hardness is and there's like
something that's in sight that I think I
can go to or there are fundamental
things that have
changed that make my original hypothesis
wrong and so I'm I'm I'm telling the
secret right now um but for
me I won't quit if no new information
has come to light and so if I say I'm
going to do this based on these
assumptions if those assumptions have
have still held then it's a push
situation if there's new data that's
come to light that
changes the nature of why I'm pushing or
the outcome for what I'm going to get
from pushing or the way that I'm pushing
is incorrect then I would quote quit but
quitting has a lot of um heavy
terminology in you know I'd say personal
motivation masturbation pivots much
softer right because I think that
everything is a pivot except for
stopping and so I think even reframing
like language matters a lot and I care a
lot about language and so like nothing
is quitting unless you stop and if you
continue to Pivot and you continue to
push either of those are activity and so
you will stumble upon something that
does work in which case do more of it um
and so that has always been my frame but
it's I have an initial assumption or
series of assumptions for a desired
thing so let's say I want to I want to
build my social media brand I say okay I
believe that if I make you know content
about things that no one else can make
content about that is more higher level
business stuff than is out there because
most of the YouTubers are YouTubers not
business people there will be an
audience for that and in the beginning I
will have fewer people who follow it but
if I make really good stuff over time
eventually people would tell people and
I will get better at making content and
that will grow so if I'm at year two
and and it's and the thing is is like do
I have leading indic ators and so like
even in business stuff like we I don't
need the outcome but are there lead
leading indicators that are telling me
that this I'm on the right path and so
identifying ahead of time just like we
have a problems that we identify like
okay if we succeed like people are going
to recognize you in the street you're
not going to be able to go out as much
like all these other these are problems
that I'm have to deal with cool I'm
willing to pay for those but what are
the what are the things along the way
that will tell me that even though I
haven't achieved Mr Beast them that I'm
on the right path and so I think having
those little indicators allow you to
keep taking steps towards the the
ultimate thing and continue to push I
mean I have a different um tweet which
is that the world belongs to those who
can continue to work without seeing the
result of their work continue to do
without seeing the result of they're
doing and it's really the person who can
do that for the longest period of time
and that's usually because they're still
getting leading indicators it's just
that it's am mounting to a much bigger
mountain and so like if you want to do
big [__] it takes a way longer period of
time because the the easy [__] the
little Hills everyone conquers really
quickly I'm on time I say please and
thank you it's like so [__] what and
so like if you want to do something that
most people can't do literally just
extend the time Horizon on the things
that most people can't weather like
there's so much opportunity on the other
side of being willing to persist for an
extended period of time on the correct
path without getting positive
reinforcing from your environment and
the longer you can stick with something
without that positive feedback loop in
terms of the big external thing the the
the easier the opportunities are because
so few people can pursue them in James
Clay's Atomic habits I think he
interviews
maybe the Chinese weightlifting team's
head coach and he asked what is the
difference between the absolute Elite
world champions and the ones that simply
qualify and the coach said the absolute
Elite are the ones who can continue to
come in every single day without getting
bored that was it and Matt Fraser talks
about it as well where he says
that doing an hour and a half of
monostructural work on the rower you've
got to do zone two hey guess what you
don't even get the benefit of feeling
like you work that hard you just get to
kind
of
yeah whatever like 24 Strokes a minute
or something like slow zone two whatever
the whatever the thing is um but no
one's fired up for that he said people
make a mistake in believing that I'm
fired up to go and do that session I'm
not fired up to go and do that session I
just go and do that
session we was saying um so there's a
lot of people say like do the work um
and in gym launch and it's continued
into our stuff today but do the boring
work is what we call it and uh boring is
what make you rich boring the boring
activities it's the it's the
double-checking the emails it's writing
the follow-up sequence that you really
don't feel like writing and honestly
just getting it done will make you
significantly more money than not
getting it done and so it's like it's
it's it's following with a lead from a
month ago and just being like hey by the
way are you still interest in that thing
it's the stuff that you don't want to do
like no one's like I can't wait to
follow up with these leads that haven't
resp resp to the last two text messages
I
sent but if you respond if you follow up
to everybody you will make more sales
than presuming that it's an effective
strategy because there are ways that you
can continue to chug away and do a thing
with no positive reinforcement but hey
guess what that's the direction that
you're supposed to be going in and
you're walking over there yeah that's a
push and pivot right like if if no one
responds then I would say I have zero
leading indicators but if you have
enough response rates then it then it's
worth the the toil um but I I so I mean
Michael Phelps talks about this too with
h with swimming like just laps after
laps after like he doesn't even have the
variety of like different moves or
different like it's just laps just sheer
volume of work and
um I call the rocky cut scene and almost
every successful person that I have ever
encountered has gone through not a month
or a year but many years of doing work
without reward where they have to do
things that other people find boring and
they have to sacrifice things that
everyone finds interesting that most
people want to do during that entire
season of their life and they basically
sacrifice a season of other things that
they would prefer to do to do stuff that
they would not prefer to do because of
the one thing they want most
and that's the rocky cut scene and
instead of lasting five minutes it just
usually lasts five or 10 years you're
going to lose sleep
you'll doubt whether it'll work you'll
stress to make ends meet you won't
finish your to-do list you'll wonder
whether you made the right call and have
no way to know for yours this is what
hard feels like and that's okay
everything worth doing is hard and the
more worth doing it is the harder it is
the greater the payoff the greater the
hardship if it's hard good it means no
one else will do it more for
you I think a lot of Entrepreneurship
and even personal growth is training
yourself on how you respond to
hard because in the early days hard was
ooh stop this isn't good I should I
should this is a warning sign this is a
red flag I should slow down or I should
stop you know I should pivot but the
more I think about it as a competitive
landscape as I'm clear on what this path
is supposed to look like and these rocks
and these dragons are things that I'm
going to have to slay along the way to
get the princess or get the treas
treasure I get happier about the harder
it is because I know that no one else
will follow it's a selection effect and
I think if you can if you can shift from
this is hard to no one else will be able
to do this then it it's it flips from
being this thing that you're like oh
poor me to oh poor everyone else who's
going to have to [__] try yeah and I
think that is so much more motivating as
a frame for the exact same circumstance
yeah that's
awesome I was
thinking a lot about the lonely chapter
that we talked about the last time that
was the best most powerful idea I think
that we came up with
and if you
see there basically being no shortcuts
toward getting the thing that you want
there are ways to be more and less
efficient there are ways to do things
with more and less of a positive
disposition which can actually make the
journey feel an awful lot easier but
ultimately if you assume that largely
everyone needs to go through the same
challenges that you're going
through every single difficult thing
that you do is kind of like a massive
wall that you need to get over and you
go wow [__] I'm so glad that I've got
over that wall and think about how many
people are going to be selected out it's
like the Hunger Games you know think
about how many other people are going to
fall that wall
there people only root for people who
don't need
it like the amount of times when I was
on my lonely path where I was too
different from the friends that I had
but not successful enough to be friends
with the people that I wanted to be
friends
with that's when that's when you want
people to root for you that's when you
want people to support you once you've
already won people are like he's amazing
he's so good but like that's the time
when you need it the least and
so you always have to be the person who
roots for you before everyone else
does and it's usually a single clap in
the auditorium for a very long period of
time it is a slow clap that's just you
rooting for you um and that visual I
think is one that you can kind of take
because it
is people struggle to do things
alone and the path of the exceptional
person is one of an exception which
means that you are not with other people
and rather than fighting that or
bemoaning it see it as an indicator that
you're on the right path because if
everyone else were cheering you on then
it means you're not in the right place
because it means you're just like
everyone else and that's not where you
want to
be it's an interesting Paradox
that the energy it requires to start
doing something is way more than the
energy required to continue doing the
thing and that the beginning of doing
anything results in the lowest amount of
reward both internal and external than
when you've been doing it for ages so I
think about this a lot with the show
that there was this stat that Spotify
told us 85% of the listeners of this
show found this in
2023 right and I thought at the end of
2022 remembering at that point I'd been
on Rogan we were at like 650k we've got
you know we've been doing 550 600
episodes deep like I'm I've got it I've
done the thing like this is is me doing
if this isn't [__] doing the thing
I've moved to Austin Texas I've got an
01 Visa I've got like the all the rest
of the stuff Jordan Peterson's been on
twice you've been
on and yet
the
what everything up until that point
is two months of
growth yeah I mean we made we made more
money for just from a revenue
perspective we made more money and more
subs in one month December of last year
than we did in the entire first three
and half half years of the show so it's
this odd Paradox and one of the things
that you need to ensure I've had this
idea about protect your passion at all
costs because if you if you begin to
hate the thing that you do you
negatively change your trajectory and
that means that at the time when you can
benefit the most by every single unit of
work which is the later that you go
presuming that you continue to hit that
upper trajectory if you've completely
killed any passion or desire to do the
work in the early stages because you
you've not protected it appropriately
that can be by focusing on the wrong
things by not rewarding yourself by not
building it with people that care about
you by you know just not not celebrating
when you hit Milestones all of the
things that actually help to keep you
going being a
character by the time that you get to
the stage where each unit of effort
allows you to gain a thousand or a
million of each of the things that it
would have done at the very beginning
you've inverted the like the passion
equation take takes way more energy to
start a thing than to continue doing a
thing and yet in the beginning the
rewards are way lower than they are at
the end but if you don't protect your
passion your motivation is at its lowest
when you are at your highest amount of
efficiency in terms of returning your
time put in I think a hopeful message
that anyone can think about who's about
who's in that hard period or in that
start period is
that it won't get harder like this is
the hardest part and so if you can just
make it through this everything else is
downhill it's not that the things that
you're the dragons are going to slay
aren't going to get bigger they are but
you become so much more equipped to slay
them back and you have so many more
allies you have people on the stands
cheering for you you have the audience
you have all of these other things that
are behind you but in the beginning it's
just you with a stick against a bear and
arguably that fight is a harder fight to
win than beating a dragon when you have
a nuclear bomb and Six Nations behind
you and so it's not even like the
the size of the hardship it's just also
the resources and how few of them you
have and how so much of the beginning is
literally burning the one thing you have
which is time because you have no
leverage you don't have the money to pay
other people to help you you don't have
the resources to go like get someone to
to you no one can learn it for you it's
like there's a lot of the things that
that we care about a lot like no one can
work out for you doesn't matter how much
money you have no one can learn skills
for you and so in the early days like it
feels so painful cuz you're like you
look around to see who can help you and
then you're like [__] it's me again and
I think getting comfortable with the
idea that each of these things kind of
like Slum Dog Millionaire if you've seen
that movie where he I'll give you the
tldr he goes through his entire life of
Randomness and he gets on Who Wants To
Be A Millionaire version in India and it
has 12 questions to make a million
dollars and from only 12 random
experiences in his life that seemed
meaningless at the time was he able to
answer all of the questions and then
ultimately win the skills that you
develop along the way like Steve Jobs
learning calligraphy that then became
Apple fonts that you know transformed
how we
type those early days that little trench
winning in the
weeds often times gives you these huge
advantages later on because you have
more context than anyone else and so
rather than lament them and hate the
fact that you're going through it
remembering that these will be arrows
that you put in the quiver that you're
going to be using to slay the future
bigger dragons and
so expecting it to be easy is what makes
it much harder than it ever
is I've always loved earning my stripes
with the things that I've done whether
it was with nighlife or running the
podcast or doing whatever and I
think there's like a degree of nobility
to it but functionally that's kind of
that's just like it's a nothing like
what's the where do the is the nobility
but I think the reason that you can feel
Noble about it and the reason that it
gives you a positive reward is is you
know that you understand every single
inch of the things and that if you want
to hold a conversation we went out for
dinner with our new CFO and and accounts
people on Saturday they said you ask a
lot of questions most people don't ask
very many questions and I also don't
care at all about accounts really like
I'm not doing this for money but they
said you ask a lot of questions said
well I don't ever really want to walk
into a room and not be able to hold my
own at least just
competently if it's to do with something
that I care about the same thing goes
for this like I I started to learn about
focal lengths and frame rates and
negative fill reverse contrast lighting
and then sure enough two years after we
started doing it a bunch of different I
sent you the Instagram thing like this
really awesome film Instagram that had
been following for ages picked us up for
what we were doing and gave us props
independent of the talk thing which is
fundamentally what we're here for and we
created this entire new industry of like
cinematic podcasting which was
recognized by as far as I'm aware like
the
best cinematic it's called filmlight at
filmlight people can go and see it on
Instagram like the best decoder and
analyzer of cinematography and two years
ago when we started I remember thinking
[__] like I love the way that they've
broken down what happens in ad asra oh
my God the whole thing was shot on 35 M
each different scenes got two pairings
of colors and stuff like that and then
but the reason that we were able to get
there at least in some part is I can
have a conversation with people so each
of the things that you do when you not
only win in the weeds but live in the
weeds then allows you Downstream from
that to see the things that other people
aren't
seeing there's a quote that I love from
Dr cash I'll probably butcher it
but
experts have more ways to win than
beginners do and so if an expert goes
into any setting that they're expert in
they have so many faster feedback loops
that reward them in the moment before
the ultimate outcome so if you're a
master video editor there's so many
things you can do that while editing you
make one change and then it looks right
you have a positive feedback loop and so
I think when you're on the start path
you can't look at the outcome as The
only positive because you will never
make it and so the positive frame that
I've always used is sure you can have
the external ones of like I like
thinking about my first videos had like
133 views and I'm like well if I had an
audience of 13 people I used to spend
years pitching you know weight loss
stuff to rims of 13 and that was fine
and so thinking about that way was
helpful but the the most helpful frame
was thinking about who I was becoming as
the asset that I was building so in real
time whenever I finished a Long Day's
Work I was becoming more like the type
of person who could work for 5 years
without reward and that would be part of
the story I would someday tell and some
some of the biggest reinforces I've had
in my life has been futurecasting the
story that I would tell about the shitty
period that I was in like I remember
when I was sleeping on the floor at my
gym because I didn't have enough money
for two rents and I was like I will
[__] tell this story and when I lost
everything for the first time I like I
have the screenshot of the bank account
like when I show it people are like oh
look there's that thing but they forget
that there was a person who screenshot
at it to be like this won't [__]
happen again and I think having a larger
narrative
of where you're ultimately going one
gives you the vision of where you're
like the like knows where he's going but
it allows the dragons that you have to
slay along the way the hard things that
you have to overcome to feed into the
larger Narrative of who of the story
that you'll someday tell and so like no
one ever tells stories about the hero
who made it all happen immediately and
had no hardships no one cares right like
okay you were born to a billionaire is
there a story there not really but
everyone loves the story because we can
see ourselves in the character and how
much we hope to be like them and it's
the being like them not the having what
they have that we usually like and so
reframing ourselves as the hero of that
narrative in my harder times was what
really got me through that and
thinking I will tell this story someday
have you heard Rogan talk about the be
the hero of your own story thing M oh
dude this is old now I think this is
maybe maybe even 10 years old 10 years
old um and he's in one of his old he's
in the LA podcast studio and he says
imagine that you're in a movie and
imagine the movie begins now and you're
the hero of the movie yeah what would
that guy do
yeah what would that guy do right now
yeah because you
are I just got into business um so
actually I just made the investment in
school um and I was talking to Sam the
founder and I said what sim sam Sim what
SIM SIM that's the way he says his own
oh yeah um and I was and I was talking
to him and I said I want to give you the
single easiest razor to predict my
behavior and I said whatever will be the
most epic story is the thing that I will
most likely
do and so often times the most epic
story is not the shortest outcome to
Victory it's the long sag that results
in this big thing later eventually and I
was like if you ever want to know if
you're like I'm not sure what he's going
to do in this situation just wonder what
the most epic story to tell would be and
that's usually what I will do
and I don't know if that's self-rising
but that's that's genuinely my Razor for
even making the like the big decisions
about okay I'm going to sell gym launch
I'm going to I'm going to marry Lila I'm
going to slum it and live at the gym I'm
going to fly around and do turnarounds
I'm going to start this whole idea of a
media company that just gives
exclusively like how do like how do I
put all these together it's like well
what would be the most epic story and I
thought of this idea of just like when I
think about who that story I want to
tell is is this billionaire that
documented the entire thing the whole
way and just gave because I always
thought I was like I wish that Elon Musk
and and Warren Buffett and all these
guys would have like and Jeff basos like
would have just like I would love to
have seen 199 7 Amazon content and a lot
of the content in terms of like it it's
getting five views it's like it's okay
because when we make it they're going to
come back and watch this so I don't need
them to watch it today I want them to
know that it's here when I do and I
think that got me out of the the loop of
it I have to win right now and then
every one of them is just dropping uh a
kernel or a bread comom for future meat
to refer back to until you win f it
always goes and noticed get used to it
no one roots for you until everyone
roots for you that's just how it works
yeah yeah people only root for those who
don't need to be rooted
for
it's strange to think
about how mimetic and fallible everyone
me and you everybody that's listening to
this
is the stuff that I've said on this
podcast for like six years since the
first time that I ever said it seven
years and it's only been within the last
18 months that it's gone viral it's the
same sentence the exact same sentence
said into the same microphone slightly
nicer
lighting
and in some ways it's reassuring because
you go I [__] knew that was right I
knew that thing that I was saying was
right and I kept saying it until people
realized that it was right but another
part of it
is the medium matters more than the
message in many ways the frame matters
more than the
picture I would say that the medium the
medium and the message are inextricably
linked like if Elon Musk tweets I'm
taking a [__] it will get a zillion
shares no because he's the richest man
on earth and has done more
entrepreneurial Endeavors that have
pushed Humanity I think more than anyone
else at this point
and so like you can't separate the
message from the messenger and I
remember when I was in Middle School I
learned this lesson where I was in
Spanish class and there was you know
there was the class clown or whatever
and I was like I want people to laugh at
my jokes and so I made a joke that was a
joke that that guy probably would have
made and it was a self-deprecating joke
um but the thing is is that like that
guy was kind of a bum and like him
making self-deprecating jokes made sense
because of the context of who he was but
I was a straight A student who was
really good at sports yeah and no one
thought it was funny and fast forward
you know 10 years there was a joke that
had in our fraternity which is there's
nothing funny about an in shaped
body and so like the the I agree with
you and that the me the the medium of
the message matters and so people won't
root for you because we use the the
delivery mechanism usually as a filter
for whether we should even trust the
sword
and so I tell the story of the the
teacher who's talking about dollar cost
averaging into the S&P and giving
investing
advice like they might be like man like
I give better investing advice than
Warren Buffett does like he's saying the
same thing as me it's like and you know
what you're probably right the only
problem is you didn't build Burkshire
hathway and so no one gives a [__] and
so the thing is is that we use someone's
evidence and Authority as a filter for
how little we need to process the
information because if you're listening
to a teacher you have to then think okay
can I separate the message from the
person can I independently analyze this
and say is it good is it bad if Warren
Buffett says you should buy this you
don't need to analyze you figure he
knows more than me he has more
perspective and I will just take it as
fact and so it's actually lazy
consumption on behalf of everyone else
that gives Authority so much resonance
and so much sharability because they're
also protected because if you share
something Elon says you're protected by
Elon and his brand and so the hard work
is getting to the point where you have
the evidence that people are willing to
feel safe agreeing with you and the only
way for them to feel safe agreeing with
you is for you to disagree with them for
a very long period of time until you
prove that you're right Rory
Sutherland's got a an idea where he says
no one gets fired for hiring KPMG yeah
such a good line and it's true people
would sooner fail by following a
blueprint that's been done before than
risk succeeding by trying something new
because if you try the new thing any
failure is on your shoulders if you
follow the BL blueprint even if it's
been total dog [__] the last 10 times
that you've tried it but we followed the
blueprint you know we did the thing that
was the same before Michael malice uh
like P literal professional Internet
troll told me when we one of the first
times that we met I wouldn't be able to
say one tenth of the [__] that I can if
I was taller than 5 foot s he's like a
small guy but he can get away with being
kind of like the Loki
of Po
on Twitter because if he's you know 6'5
and built like Alan richer yeah it's
going to seem like he's bullying yeah
but it's there's something funny about
him like like you know dip dip dipping
away there's also something the like
until you win effort always goes
unnoticed I realized this with and and
it made me like a little dispirited how
fallible people are around success so do
you remember Billy McFarland guy that
did fire Festival that festival at Pablo
Escobar Island and then everyone got
stranded and nearly died yeah um if he'd
been able to pull off an even remotely
passable event people would have hailed
him as a marketing genius yeah
regardless of the fact that he was
continually flying back to New York to
raise money in an unethical way for a
project that he didn't know if it was
going to work and all the rest of the
stuff so literally the line
between
charlatan grifter who's out of his
depth and Visionary Pioneer who makes
things work when no one else believes
that they can is just outcome everyone
thinks you're crazy until it
works and so I mean if if you think of
of the outcome as the trump card then
all of the pain and suffering that you
lead up to that point if you're
just I'm trying to think of a an
appropriate saying um I was going to say
balls deep certain um that no matter
what you will die or you will get
there then the likelihood that all of
the things that you've done up to that
point will then be justified in
retrospect is super high and I actually
see that as super
um compelling as a as a thing to latch
on to in harder
times yes but the ends justifying the
means is a slippery slope I'm a Mak guy
so have you seen speaking of that and
you mentioned Robert Green earlier on uh
you should buy the 25th anniversary
edition of 48 Laws of Power just came
out last year yeah leatherbound gold
emboss I have it oh you got it and
you've seen the thing on the edges yeah
his face is very cool the the super cool
printing yeah dude so for the people
that don't know you remember you would
get those things in packets of seral
when you were a kid and you could sort
of move a a little bit of plastic from
left to right and it would look like a
football player was running or something
like that it's basically the same but on
the edge of a book if it's flat it's
just gold foil if you open it one way so
that the pages spay out it's Robert
Green's face and if you open it so the
pages playay out in the other way it's
Macky Valley's face the
[__] coolest book just and I've seen
a lot of influencer gifting of books is
a big deal at the moment you know you
send the book out and maybe they'll post
about it and it'll help with sales or
whatever and there's some very elaborate
ways I'm sure that you've received some
of these
um because I know that you're on the
same mailing list there's some of these
that are super super elaborate and I
remember being like Oh that was like I
don't know like cool or whatever
but that Robert Green book as soon as I
saw that it did that like I'm sending a
[__] video of this to anyone that I
can like this is like magic yeah so yeah
what is it you're doing sales because
you sucked at marketing you're doing
marketing because you sucked at
product it's a great noism yeah it's so
funny cuz um like with the the book
launch I I I didn't do any of
that I just always I wanted people I
want people to read the book because
like if someone posts about the book
before the book's out then like I wanted
no one to have read the book until the
day it was out you know um but yeah I'm
the the longer I've been in at least the
business game and we were talking about
legendary Foods um it's just product
like I had a roommate way back in the
day who's now a really successful
entrepreneur and we were both like early
days poor as [__] um we Happ to live
together and he read this book he just
told the title and just like stuck with
me he said too good to
fail and I just love that as a frame
it's like if I open a sandwich shop how
can I make the sandwiches too good like
just if someone takes a bite they're
like [__] this is the best sandwich I've
ever had like if you just get that then
the rest of it doesn't matter and so
when you're like I mean I think about
this in business decisions but probably
also in life decisions is I think Tim
Ferris talks about this the one big
Domino it's like what is the one thing
that if I just get this one thing right
everything else shrinks into
irrelevance and I think about that from
like the hero story of what you said
with Joe Rogan which I love that frame
it's like okay boom now you're present
in your movie what would that guy do
it's like well what one big thing could
that guy accomplish that would make all
of the all of the mediocrity of your
life up to this point are
relevant and why are you not putting
every single ounce of your effort to
prove that one point so that you could
then justify everything up to that point
so it wouldn't have been mediocrity it
would have been the path to get there
exact thank you it would have been the
journey people want to find their
passion but you don't find it you create
it and you create it by getting good at
something and to get good at stuff you
start by doing something you suck at
then you get good then you like it then
people ask how you found your passion
answer by starting when you sucked and
not giving
up yeah I hate the passion Mantra I
really do I mean part of it was because
um I'll even I'll even play it out so I
I read all the same self-help books
early on when I was you know in my
entrepreneurial days and I was trying to
find my passion and I was into fitness
and so I was deciding between fitness
test prep because I was good at test
prep and uh frozen yogurt because I like
dessert right so I've like these are my
three quote passions which let's just
translate that into things you're
interested in and so as soon as I
started the gym my
passion disappeared it became work and I
had a different Mentor later in my life
who said never create work around your
passion because then it'll become work
and he was a guy who's a very successful
business guy and I think about that
actually more than I than I share
because it's just complete and utter
[__] because it assumes that what
you're going to be doing every day is
the thing that you're currently really
interested which also doesn't make you
money and so your behavior has to change
and whenever you're doing these new
things one the they'll be new which
means you will suck at them which means
you'll probably not like them but it's
also part of it and so like I would
prefer to take the extreme opposite
position of everything will suck and
eventually you will get good at the
things that you suck at and then you'll
enjoy being competent at that thing
which will then probably give you status
and you'll enjoy the fruits of status
more than the pain of doing the thing
and in so doing create a positive
feedback loop that you'll actually keep
sticking with it and so I'd rather set
the expectation that everything is
terrible all the time for
forever now let's see if we can make our
now let's see if we can become the
person who can still do it anyways um
and start that as the Baseline rather
than trying to assume that I need
perfect conditions in order to start
because I mean starting is the perfect
condition like whatever condition that
you're in that you start was the perfect
condition there is such a thing is
intrinsic motivation though as well as
extrinsic you can do something there's a
whole myriad of things that you could be
potentially good at and many of them
could give you Renown and and and money
and social clout and that feedback loop
but there are some that you will enjoy
doing for the sake of doing them more I
don't disagree I was remember a note
that I wrote to myself when I first
started the podcast and I decided to
turn pro with it which
is one way to turn something you love
into a labor is to monetize it
okay because as soon as you decide that
you're going to really really go for
this if you want to turn pro at
something I use this example in in my
live show of a pickle ball player so
this guy loves playing pickle ball and
he gets to turn up on a Saturday and
play with his friends you know if it's
cold outside he doesn't need to go and
play and if he's tired he doesn't need
to go and play and if he's hung over he
doesn't need to go and play and then he
decides to turn pro and he thinks I'm
turning pro at this thing that I love I
can't wait to make what I love into my
career but he doesn't realize that hey
guess what if you're hung over you still
need to go and train yeah or actually no
you don't get to be hung over anymore
because the guy that isn't hung over is
the guy that's training better so you
now need to stop going out with your
friends and you need to train when it's
cold and you need to work on game tape
and mindset and hydration and nutrition
you need to do snc and you need to have
a Physio and you need to not see a
family as much all of these things came
along for the ride as soon as you
decided to turn
pro is that a price that you're prepared
to pay and that's an interesting
question to ask yourself am I prepared
to sacrifice my pure unencumbered
unmolested love for this thing in order
to try and become the best at this
thing I think it's really tough and I'm
I'm gonna I'm gonna shoot I'm gon to
shoot my own advice right now in the in
the head or at least my positioning
right now which is that it's very easy
for someone in you know my position or
in your position to say this is kind of
what it takes and or rather this is like
you should find your passion because
like transparently what I do now every
day I actually really do love um I live
more or less the same day seven days a
week and um like I'll tell you what it
is just so we can have context but I
wake up and then I go to my office here
and I work for 6 hours writing my next
book and then I take two hours is of
calls typically and then after that I
lift in the gym that I custom designed
with all the pieces that I love and then
I go and eat with my wife and then I go
to my condo and I sit in my recliner
that overlooks the entire city and I
read and then I go to bed and I do that
every day and I love every aspect of the
day with the exception of maybe the two
hours of calls that I have to take but I
see those as a necessary thing for
everything else that I have there now
could I stop doing that maybe but for me
to
say that that's what your day needs to
look like in order to get into the top
floor with the view that looks over
these things and so that you can not
make money for 2 years while you write a
book that eventually makes money or
whatever is is not true and so it's the
difference
between like oh I should fly private
because that's what rich people do I
should play basketball because I want to
be tall and modeling the top the
behavior at the top of the mountain
rather than the climb and so they're
completely different and so this whole
idea unfortunately and I don't blame the
people who do this is they see their
current life like I would see mine and
say well what do I do now I do
everything that I love okay okay but I
didn't get here doing everything that I
love I did a fuckload of [__] I hate and
I did it for a very long period of time
and I did not have anyone to root me on
and in fact I had many people who were
actively trying to destroy my path and
tell me why it was a terrible
idea I had this idea about um why you
should stop taking advice from
successful people MH because most of
their advice is not about what they did
when they were at your stage it's about
what they do now right and it's the same
thing around pushing work life balance
you know I what I found after 50 years
at Disney is that really the most
important thing is what all right well
how did you get to this stage what did
you do when you were two years in
because that's where I am yeah what did
you do when you were broken living on
the gym floor because that's where I am
don't tell me about the complicated
routine or the the the the balance or
the flying private the bar stool's
upside down and you're you're mixing up
the ends for the means
everything on my write up so this is I
mean I I remember in a lot of
excruciating detail what it took me to
get here um but I will say that I had a
ruthless focus on dollars per hour and
so and I'm just giving tactical advice
right now but everything that I could
trade away for more time doing the thing
that made me money was what I did and so
I remember the first time I made a five
00 sale and it took me 30 minutes and I
was like every hour of every day this is
what I going to do and anything that is
not talking to someone in exchange for
them giving me a credit card so that I
can charge it and make
$500 anything that makes me less than
$250 per hour or per per 30 minutes I'm
giving to somebody else and so after
that first sale was like I'm never
cooking again I'm never going grocery
shopping again I'm not cleaning again
because I knew that in one sale I could
pay for that person for the month and so
like as like the ruthless focus on what
can I do that creates an input to Output
being money equation and me at least for
me it was pouring everything I possibly
could into the input and eliminating
everything else I made this video on
Facebook before I was quote Alex rosi
years ago when I still had six gyms
before I even did the turnarounds and I
I made this video almost this
documentation but I said so I want to
open up my 7th 8th n9th and 10th
location and I have the spots picked out
and I'm already working all of the hours
that I'm awake and I've already given up
Saturdays so the only thing that I have
left is like Sundays and
evenings and so I am no longer going to
be watching any football and I'm no
longer going to have Netflix at all and
that is what I'm giving up for seven
eight n and
10 and I remember just making this video
of like that's what I'm sacrificing and
I think a lot of people create these
Todo lists when in my experience it's
been so much more useful to write down
all the things that I'm willing to
sacrifice because if you sacrifice
everything there's nothing left than to
do the one thing that matters and I
think Jerry Seinfeld talks about this
from a writing perspective he says that
every day no matter what he sits down
and he writes for two hours now he
doesn't have to write but he's not
allowed to do anything else and so he
can sit there but there's nothing else
to do except for write
jokes and so I think a lot about that
from The Climb perspective which is like
most of everyone who's listening to this
who isn't achieving what they want is
[__] with their time they think that
they're spending all their time working
but your output like you don't even know
how to work I'm being really real with
you like you think you know how to work
you don't know how to work like the
amount of output like and I I'll measure
this by like what is your output it's
probably not as high as you think and so
rather than trying to learn all these
productivity hacks the ultimate
productivity hack is
no n o is you stop doing [__] and then
when you create space then you can fill
it with the thing that matters but
trying to add on more to your schedule
of all the things that you're not
willing to sacrifice is the very reason
that you're not doing what you need to
do a lot of people would look at that
life of I'm going to sacrifice evenings
and I'm not going to watch football
anymore and say well what's the point if
you make yourself miserable on route to
achieving the goal totally if most of
your life is Journey not
destination and it makes you miserable
on root to it why do that so that was
the thing I was mentioning earlier where
it's like let's take the absolute
extreme of it's going to suck and it's
going to last forever how can I be okay
in that circumstance and I do have the
fundamental belief that circumstances
nothing to do with how what your
subjective well-being is and so if monks
can be super chill in wherever monks do
monk things and have nothing and have
higher subjective well-being ratings
than anyone else here in the Western
World it clearly isn't
external and so then if I'm going to be
just as miserable being mediocre as I am
doing this [__] that's going to amount
to something then I might as well do the
[__] that's going to amount to something
and be miserable there and at least have
something to show for
it does this story I learned about
Victor Hugo famous writer from history
do you know this about what he did with
his servant M so um Victor Hugo needed
to make himself right so he paid his
servant each night during the middle of
the night to come into his bedroom and
remove the bed clothes from him turn the
heating off and then lock his bedroom
door from the outside and he wasn't
allowed to leave until Victor
slid six pages of handwritten work
underneath so you know you look at opal
which is this app for um iPhone which
stops you from using apps or frozen
turkey uh cold turkey which is the same
thing for desktop and uh that's just the
digital equivalent of Victor Hugo being
locked in his bedroom with no bedding
and just a quill and a few pieces of
paper and then having to slide it
underneath the door and I want to push
back on something that you said right
before Victor Hugo which is you know
somebody somebody might ask like why
would you do all this stuff if you're
not happy that assumes that my goal in
life is to be happy what is your goal in
life to do epic
[__] genuinely to be
useful and so why Place do epic [__]
over be
happy because when I look back on my
life in retrospect the things that bring
me the most joy in the moment are the
things that I was willing to sacrifice
for for an extended period of time and
those pay memory dividends far greater
than the momentary cost that I had in
the moment and so I think it's a a
long-term short-term thing
but a frame
that continued to paralyze me for a long
period of time was an obsession with
happiness like it was truly an obsession
it was an obsession of mine in college I
almost almost got into positive
psychology because I thought that was
really interesting that's what I that's
what I my passion right I consumed all
that stuff and I drove myself mad with
it and I actually was more sad and
depressed than anything which is
probably why I was trying to find all
this positive uh dippy stuff
and I just cracked one day and I was
like [__]
happiness because it felt so Out Of
Reach that I was like just [__] it I'm
just not I'm not even I'm not even going
to shoot for it I'm just G to do stuff
and that's all I'm going to do I'm just
going to do stuff and what happened was
like a few years later dot dot do a few
days later um I looked up and I was like
huh I'm not not
miserable and so I actually identified
for a very long period of time as I'm
not a happy person comma and that's okay
I'm fine with that I accept that and
there was this huge Conflict for such a
long period of time where I was like
you're supposed to be happy why aren't
you happier like there's something wrong
there's something wrong with you
something needs to
change rather than saying like maybe the
level of happy that you are is
fine who am I like what happy am I
comparing myself to and also if whatever
your current state is if you just say
like happyer which is really when people
are like I want to be happy they're just
saying I want to be happyer than I am
which means that you create this
distance between where you are and where
you want to be which is the recipe for
being unhappy is saying that I want to
be happy ER so it doesn't matter how
happy you are you want to be happy and
so by relinquishing the desire to be
happy I ended up enjoying a lot more of
the stuff that I was doing because I did
make it a requisite for for my
activities so then it became a pleasant
surprise I was like oh this doesn't suck
huh how nice two famous psychologists
Daniel Gilbert and Daniel caraman have
uh quite Divergent views on happiness is
quite interesting so uh Daniel Gilbert
talks about how if you spent every
minute of the rest of your life on a
floaty Lilo in a pool drinking cocktails
in retrospect you might not have found
much meaning but each individual moment
of experience would have been enjoyable
and he believes that constitutes to him
a life that is well lived I disagree
with this guy entirely Daniel Carman and
this is my position too which is a
well-lived life is one which in
retrospect you are glad that you lived
right uh so one is leaning toward
hedonic pleasure and the other is
leaning toward meaning so one you could
say is happiness and the other is
meaning it's my belief that your
disposition largely influences where on
that Spectrum from Lilo to do hard
things you need to sit and you will have
friends and I did for a very long time
in The Nightlife industry have friends
that just seem to be so [__] happy
not doing stuff like just they would
float through life and they wouldn't ask
themselves am I actualizing my [__]
virtue is this the highest Integrity
that I can do with these things and all
the rest of it and I was envious of
those people you ever seen a dog you see
a dog on the floor and it's just lying
there and you think oh my God if only I
could beat that dog like it just wants
to go for walk and have food and and
like go pee pee that's it that's all it
wants to do and you think [__] it would
be great to be that dog but like guess
what if your Constitution doesn't allow
you to be that dog the only way out is
through and this was something the first
time that I went to go and see Peterson
someone asked him a question and they
said the depth of my Consciousness
causes me to suffer is it a blessing or
a curse to feel everything so
deeply he thought for a little bit and
he
said take more of the thing that poisons
you until you turn it into a tonic that
girdles the world around you the only
way out is through and it's kind of like
as soon as you realize that there are
things that you do that give you
satisfaction and there are things that
other people do that give them happiness
and you've tried that
route the only way is to continue doing
the thing that you know that works and I
think that you were an example of
someone who is optimizing heavily for
meaning rather than for Hedonism and
that's not to say that there are people
and this is I said this on the last
episode the fundamental thing that
people don't understand as far as I can
tell about your worldview is that the
thing that you do for work and the thing
that you do for fun of the same
thing they can't imagine that because
that's not the way that it is for them
and it's not maybe the way it is for
most
people
but if you're the sort of person
that finds meaning more enjoyable than
happiness you need to optimize for the
thing that you enjoy the
most and I'll toss in and meaning lasts
longer and so I I'll be super upfront if
that those friends of yours in in the
night
life I've there's nothing wrong with
that in my in my way like as I see the
world like if that's you and you're like
I [__] love everything I do then like
you won like just keep doing that you
know what I mean um but I think a lot of
the message that Chris saying here is if
you've tried that path and it hasn't
worked for you then you have this dark
door that's in the corner that you've
been trying all the other ones that have
nice gold edges and really shiny things
but there's that door that you keep
looking at and it's the other side of
you that's clearing his throat in the
other room and it's like you just have
to bust through the door and I think
that the like giving yourself permission
to be unhappy or at least for me giving
myself permission to be unhappy for an
extended period of time in order to get
what I wanted gave me so much relief
from honestly I don't like using the
word nowadays because it has so many
associations but just from like the
depression or the funk that I was in for
a few years yeah I just I just didn't
like my life and I'd achieved by most
measure because I I did I don't have the
um I you know School failed me I was
whatever like I wasn't that I finished
in three years and I did really well in
school and I had a really good job um
but it was empty for me and
so my like my goal is things we talked
about earlier but my my personal goal is
to squeeze every ounce of potential out
of whatever I have and I think that if
you feel like you have potential left
over then it will eat you alive until
you do something about
it not to piss off the positive Poes in
the room but if you haven't gotten what
you want then you're not worthy of it
period and that's okay now you can admit
that you suck and improve better to know
you're bad for a season then pretend
you're good for a lifetime you're not
making as much money as you want because
you're not as good as you think you are
you're not struggling from imposter
syndrome you're a student and pretending
to be a teacher no students say they
feel like like frauds for trying to
learn you're a fraud when you get up to
teach the class and you've never done
it
deep I think it's just giving yourself
permission to suck it's giving yourself
permission to be unhappy it's giving
yourself permission to not achieve while
you do for a long period of time it's
giving yourself permission to lose
friends it's giving yourself permission
to do things that's different than
people your Social Circle or your age
group are doing it's giving you
permission giving yourself
permission to be an exception so that
you can become exceptional and a lot of
that the whole positive poly Mantra of
like the I saw that I saw a post a girl
made and she was like you are worthy and
that's what made that tweet all my
tweets are just responses to [__] I see
and so this girl was like you like I say
this to myself in the morning like you
are worthy you are amazing you are a
goddess and I was like you're not a
goddess cuz you don't control me um and
you don't have the things that you want
you keep thinking that you saying that
you're worthy is going to somehow make
it true but like the way that you know
you're worthy is that you have
it that's it like that is the litus test
are you worthy of a billion doar well
are you a billionaire no then you're not
worthy and so just like I think we have
these things it's it's like uh you're
unbalanced it's like you're not worthy
there's these things that we're
programmed to say oh that's bad you have
to tell everyone they're Worthy you're
everyone's beautiful no if everyone were
beautiful then no one's beautiful and
yet again we're back at square one and
so it's it's I guess drinking the tonic
it's
it's going through the [__] which is
honestly the boring stuff that no one
wants to do for an extended period of
time and
uh accepting that you
suck and that it is okay because the
first step is accepting that you stuck
you suck so that you can do the Second
Step which is doing something about it
what about you're not making as much
money as you want because you're not as
good as you think you are
that's I mean I'm obviously in the
business space and that follows up with
the other one with the Imposter syndrome
like people are like man um how do you
not suffer from impostor syndrome I was
like because I've done what I said I've
done and the people who get up on stage
and try and teach a class on [__] they
haven't done it's like that like you
feel like an impostor when you're an
impostor like don't try and kill that
voice listen to that voice and get the
evidence to make that voice shut the
[__] up like if like if I get on stage
and I say I can bench
315 is there like do I feel like an
imposter when I say that no I stay fact
presumably if you're if you're
pioneering and breaking new ground you
know you're you just put the biggest
investment that you ever did into this
new thing that is a new level that you
get to and that's one that's to do with
Finance but there could be another one
that's to do with capacity or competence
you could be sitting down in a room
doing a deal which is time Bound in a
way that it's never been before or is in
an industry only tangential to one that
you've been in before each time that you
do something new by definition you're an
impostor because you haven't done it
before now if you're teaching that's
different but if you're entering if
you're growing sufficiently quickly most
of the time it's fresh snow so I like
this is a f a topic I love but I think
the difference between doing something
new and being an impostor is one is
pretending you be something that they're
not so like I made the biggest
investment school I'm making a bet that
I think communities are going to be huge
and I think that there's a ton of people
who want to you know teach skills they
have in communities Etc and school.com
can help but
like it would only be an imposter if I
said this is like I guarantee it no
matter what this is going to be the
biggest thing ever
and one of the big things that I repeat
and from the marketing front I say it
all the time I say State the facts and
tell the
truth like the best Marketing in the
entire world is truth now if the truth
isn't compelling it doesn't mean you lie
it means you change the world to make
the facts
compelling as in if I say man I want to
be like I you see this one all the time
uh 18-year-olds who like want to be a
motivational speaker right you say okay
well what are your facts you've done
nothing great so they then lie so that
they can try and claim success that they
don't deserve so they can get Authority
that they can't back up and eventually
are called out and are flat and to be
fair they only impress people who don't
know anything
anyways so if they're honest about it
they look at their fact sheet and say
What would what would a motivational
speaker have to have in order for them
to have
authority and then that becomes your
action list of what you need to do and
then once those facts are the truth then
you can State the facts and tell the
truth and then people will be like wow
that's so motivational but all you did
was tell the truth and so like that is
why I've so wholeheartedly rejected one
like you are worthy you're not worthy if
you had it then you wouldn't even need
to say you were worthy because you'd
already [__] have it and if you were
and like I struggle with impostor
syndrome why you only struggle with
imposter syndrome because you're [__]
lying like that's why you feel like an
imposter and Ne like well I didn't the
thing is is you can fudge the truth like
you can you can not lie is very
different than telling the truth like I
can make something seem a certain way
without deliberately breaking the law
but I'll know and that's why you feel
like an imposter because you [__]
know and there's the guy in the other
room who's clearing his throat be like
that's not [__] true and then that
Discord but if you just say what you
have done or you say what you are doing
I'm making this big investment it's a
big bet for me the reason I'm making
this bet is because I see this trend and
I think it's a good idea I could be
[__] wrong but I'm not going to feel
like an impostor because of it because
that's the
truth thinking about the community thing
I had a conversation a little while ago
I don't I don't think that you're that
you're far off wrong especially in an
age of automation this guy made a really
great point which you probably thought
of which is one of the very few things
that you can't automate is community
can't AI community no what you're going
to have I mean maybe BS yeah yeah
exactly one guy one guy and a thousand
Bots that are all doing it maybe GPT 10
can do that or whatever but the next
this inter quartile period whatever
we're coming up to yeah is the easiest
way to to hedge against automation I
think is to focus on community all right
next one if you can be in a bad mood for
no reason you might as well be in a good
mood for no reason if it's not going to
change your life it shouldn't change
your mood if the cost is peace of mind
don't buy
it yeah if you can be in a bad mood for
no reason then you can be in a good mood
for no reason which means that if you
can do something that's amazing and
still have a [__] day it means you can
do something that sucks and have a good
day which means the entire excuse around
I don't want to do all these hard things
because as a proxy it makes my mood sad
is ridiculous because it means that we
are ultimately in control of how we want
to perceive the work that we do and so I
think that is ultimately the most
freeing thing that you can do in terms
of how you can equip yourself to get
through those harder
periods why do you think there's so much
cynicism at the moment especially on the
Internet it's easier you can always
defend no like we we actually do with
this a lot at acis.com from an
investment perspective and um we
actually have to check ourselves which
is it's always easy to find a reason not
to do an
investment so we have a no bias and you
should have I mean you should overall
have a no bias like you should say okay
here's all the things that could go
wrong and you have to kind of think that
way because you have to manage risk but
if you say no to everything you're
always right in the short
term but you're but if you never make an
investment you're wrong in the one way
that matters which is you get no return
and so like you always miss the
short-term losses but you lose the big
long-term gain and so it's again this is
a a Continuum to be managed more than a
problem to be solved but cynicism is
shortterm it's like every so when you so
okay this is so when you go home right
and you want to start a new business or
you have a girl that you're bringing
back and your friends and your family
are like she's not going to last or like
this isn't going to this isn't going to
be forever they are right literally
every single single time except for the
one time you bring your wife home and in
that time they're all wrong and it's the
one time that [__] matters and so the
idea like but the thing is is because of
the false positives or the true
positives they might have been right
literally 19 out of 20 times and if they
were right the first time and the second
time and the third time and the fourth
time why would they bet against no on
the fifth time or the 50th time but you
only need one yes or one positive to
change your entire life and so there's
this habit and that's where cynicism
comes from where we get so many positive
reinforcers for saying no and being
right but it's only short-term being
right because you have to make big bets
to win big and that also means that
you're wrong plenty of times and people
aren't willing to look stupid for being
wrong this school bet could go wrong I'm
betting it's not but everything has risk
and I've been public about it right and
so like if anything but like I've played
this out so like I like I'll tell you
how I played this out I was like if it
goes wrong I'll document the things that
I that I learned and that I'll apply
next time and I'll do what I've always
done State the facts and tell the
truth it is strange to think about
how being cynical or skeptical or kind
of sardonic or cutting or
aloof it's used as a proxy for being
smart
oh the worst thing that body could be
accused of as naive that's what they're
trying to optimize against they don't
want to be seen as naive oh you [__]
you hope that everything was going to be
good a that's I mean that's cute like
you know the world will teach you it'll
don't worry don't worry it's like it'll
it'll you'll Lear you'll Lear yeah
people don't want to be naive and
they'll be
right and that's what's that's what's
painful is that it takes more effort to
start in the beginning and more people
are right about the fact they're like
hey you're not going to hit it big and
guess what a month in you're not but
they're only measuring on months and at
6 months you're also not going to have
hit it big yet and they're going to be
like I'm still [__] right and at a
year you're still not going to hit it
big and they'll still be [__] right
and every day that you haven't hit it
they're going to feel like they were
right but they're wrong because they're
measuring in days and you're measuring
in decades there's this idea from gnda
called the cynical genius illusion
cynical people are seen to be smarter
but sizable research suggests they
actually tend to be Dumber cynicism is
not a sign of intelligence but a
substitute for it a way to Shield
oneself from betrayal and disappointment
without having to actually
think there was a there's a tweet on um
a doomsday Money Twitter guy and he said
uh yeah he's predicted uh 16 out of the
last three
recessions and the thing is is that no
one no one
recalls the other 13 times that guy was
wrong yeah and and they don't recall all
of the gains that probably were made in
the marketplace by people who didn't
sell during that time period there was
this uh broad you you know people
forward [__] on WhatsApp and if it's
been forward lots of times it even says
it the top forwarded many times it's
like a little warning and this happened
I think around uh covid there was an
image of one guy one squatty wearing
like army gear walking through the
Streets of London and this was forwarded
on what as evidence that the Army was
going to come and hold people in the
house at gunpoint and if you left it was
going to be martial law was going to be
deployed on the Streets of London and
this went [__] nuclear completely
Interstellar absolutely
everywhere what happened with that right
what happened with what happened with
that thing not a single person who
decided to spout this half [__] baked
opinion that never turned out to be true
ever got held to account for that and I
must have received that message like
five times yeah like hey you you don't
get to just make these like ridiculous
like actually stupid [__] claims
about the world and then no one call you
to
account I'm going to hit on the cynicism
Point um the world belongs to
optimists because if you're going to do
anything big you have to believe that it
can
happen otherwise it never will that Shan
Puri thing the get to be right and the
optimists get to be rich yeah like if
you look at it from a percentage of
success rate I've been wrong more times
than I've been right I have failed more
times than I've succeeded but you always
succeed more and or write more in the
big ways than the people who've been
right all along and are wrong Trevor
says this my my editor he says uh 99%
right and 100%
wrong so like they're they're right 99%
of the time but they're wrong 100%
because the only thing that matters is
the big one at the end like your family
and friends will say that every girl
that you ever a date is not good
enough except for the one time you find
the girl that you're actually going to
marry and then it doesn't matter or like
this won't last or like this business
idea it's not going to work and you
might have nine failures i f my first
nine businesses didn't really amount to
anything nine nine as in the first one
spent time [__] failed second one
this one will be different [__]
failed third one this one this is the
one and then seven six more after that
right I'm just painting this picture
because like it's painful as [__]
because the whole time everyone is
telling you I told you so and they're
right
today but not
forever if the cost his peace of mind
don't buy it
why I use the Peace of Mind as a as a
indicator for breaching
values so that's the I want to become
known rather than and sacrifice my
reputation in order to do so and so for
me I would lose piece of my like right
on the edge I'm like I don't know this
is a little bit edgy I had a guy um who
shared a A bash clip of me and what's a
bash clip oh like somebody like took my
clip and then was like this is wrong
whatever
and um and so I looked at the guy's
profile and I saw he was a VC and I was
like huh okay I know who this is oh and
so I dm' him and I was like um do you
disagree with
this and uh he said something and then I
just eviscerated him uh and he was like
you're right I overstepped because I
wanted to try and do a viral clip you
are fundamentally right and I was wrong
and so like that is what I would never
want to be like that is disgusting to me
and so the cost of making a viral
clip to try and Trend jump when I know
that fundamentally the thing isn't right
is not worth the price there's a this
shows up in in other ways so I had to
what the [__] did I
do
I I think
I tried to throw a used Splendor packet
in a bin in a restaurant you
know yeah did that but I was leaving and
I was like it's next to the bin someone
will get it and I walked oh yeah 30
yards away
yeah [__] yeah turned around went back
put it in the bin yeah you'd know that's
a pece of mind yeah
and this is another one of those
interesting reframes this is really
really interesting to me if the cost is
peace of mind don't buy
it you can see and I did for a long time
my inability to move in as ruthless of a
way as I as other people do as a
weakness as a
vulnerability
and I realized in retrospect that it's
just a higher standard that I'm holding
myself to and that can be that that will
result in many times me doing things
that and and and having things that I
need to overcome I'm working on my
people pleasing Tendencies as hard as I
can at the moment to not to not yeah I I
end up um I don't like to disappoint
people true I don't like to do things
that causes other people to feel bad or
uh feel hurt or to tell them things that
uh they don't want to hear that's why
that um Dr Robert Glover the no my Mr
Nice Guy was just so [__] like very
very very incisive uh but I realized
even with that I had I had a
conversation with a friend
and it's to do with this book and
there's a bunch of ideas that
everybody's been working on in my friend
group for quite a while and I was like I
really want to write about this thing
and sent him a long overly arduous voice
note explaining about how conflicted I
was because it's not my idea now no one
owns the truth that's one of the
brilliant things about working through
quotes and things like this is no one
owns it right like if it's accurate
nobody gets to own the truth it's just
an it about the way that reality exists
so I sent him this big long voice note
and he replied to me and
said and I in it I'm over patent
matching a lot of the things I'm doing
as people pleasing like it's the I think
I sent you that tweet about um I just
learned about the recency bias and of
all of them I have to say it's my
favorite one right it's like you see
this new thing and it's the hot new toy
that you're playing with or whatever the
like shiny new toy and uh he responded
and he
said uh I wanted to say how grateful I
am that you in amongst all of the stuff
and the book and the show and all of the
different people pulling on your
attention that the first place that you
would go to when thinking about this
idea is how I would feel rather
than how you can like Weedle it so that
you get the outcome that you want or
whatever uh I would be be very hesitant
in you saying or you calling that people
pleasing when it's one of the reasons
that I love you as a friend I was like
huh that's interesting that's a reframe
that I hadn't anticipated
and that is again the Peace of Mind
thing now your level for Peace of Mind
may be different to somebody else's but
I don't think that that's something that
you should be ashamed
of you know as a fun challenge for
anyone who's
listening try telling the
truth in Social
settings so when someone invites you to
a party instead of coming up with a fake
excuse that you both know is a fake
excuse just say I don't want to go
really [__] with
you um and if someone like says hey can
you uh you know help me move you're like
I don't want
to it's very freeing because the thing
is is that like their response is on
them and if I just I try and anchor
myself to truth if I just tell the truth
and state the facts I'm good with me and
if someone and I I ask because I had a
exchange recently where I said that um I
say it often and now people who are
around me are accustomed to the fact
that I will just State the facts and
tell the truth um I said would you have
preferred that I've lied to
you and the guy just I was like so you
would prefer that I lie I will not be
associated with someone who would prefer
that I lie to them because it makes my
life difficult because then I'd have to
lie which then would breach one of my my
values so in the future you know I I had
someone who um recently was like hey um
hey if you need anything you know let me
know how I can help i' be like you don't
mean that because if I actually need
something you will not
help and
so it's it's really uncomfortable for a
lot of people because it it breaks a lot
of social norms but I think that learn
it's kind of like the hundred NOS is
like being comfortable like it's just
being comfortable with the truth and the
truth is one of the the scariest ugliest
things you know like why don't you want
to go on another date with me I don't
like you
you're not
worthy but like people are so
uncomfortable with that and I think that
the the I've just tried to shed [__]
as much as I could for my life and it's
just made thinking a lot easier and also
dealing with relationships a lot easier
because you also by shedding social
niceties when you do also State the
truth when I say I think you [__]
killed that people know it [__]
carries weight because you don't just
say that and so I would say most of my
team for example if I pay a compliment
they know that I mean it and I don't
have to say like hey like if I'm being
honest I really you like I don't have to
I don't like and it makes your words
mean what you say and I think that is
like I I I aspire to be a man who when I
say things people know that I mean them
and I think a way to do that is to stop
saying things that I don't mean and so
I'm trying to cut as much of the words
that are niceties and things that I
don't mean and are nonsensical and
[__] that I've been taught to say in
this social situation when someone says
that make sense I say no it doesn't make
any sense people are like oh um because
when when someone says make sense at the
end of a sentence we are trained to just
nod and say yeah yeah yeah even though
if you didn't even process it but if I
don't think it makes sense I say no I
don't think it makes sense or no I don't
understand and again you don't want to
look stupid but
looking stupid in the moment so that you
can better understand something makes
you not look stupid for the rest of your
life when you actually understand it and
so I've just that has been a huge effort
of mine is
to
make make words great again um make
words mean what they mean again yeah and
I and I and I really I I Aspire do that
in my writing and I especially in my
social relationship because time is so
valuable and we have so so little of it
and I don't want to waste any of it
pretending to be someone or say things
that I don't
mean it's normal to not know what you're
doing yeah if you did it wouldn't be
called growth high-five your fear
uncertainty and doubt and carry on do
you get tired stressed sad hungry
frustrated unfocused do you feel
misunderstood great you're human you
don't need
medication I have a a huge vem distaste
for uh
mental medication and I think one is
because it's overprescribed two because
people over WebMD themselves and
fundamentally people find a problem with
being human and I think a lot of that is
because of the social Norm that we
should
be never hungry never sad never angry
never frustrated never feel like we're
misunderstood and those are the those
are the troughs and peaks of humanity
and we can't only wish for sunny days
because otherwise we'd have droughts and
no one everyone would die and so it's
wishing for something that isn't true
and will never happen it's wanting a lie
which is why I'm so against it now are
there people who they can test their
neurology and whatever maybe but like
honestly a hundred years ago this [__]
didn't
exist and people just dealt with life
and I think people were happier then
than they are now and so clearly this
solution hasn't hasn't been much of a
solution at all and so I if I I you know
I try have I don't have that many
extreme stance well maybe I do but one
of my extreme stances is that there is
nothing wrong with you because even if
there is something wrong with you how do
you benefit by saying there is something
wrong with you and then accepting that
label unto
yourself because the alternative to that
is accepting your current existence as
maybe this is better than everyone
else's and I'm just choosing to believe
that it's wrong and all of this is
around some big Mighty should that we
think and that we worship that it should
that we should be a certain way that
we're not and I think that discrepancy
that word I've tried to eliminate as
much as humanly possible from my
vocabulary because like I should what I
should nothing according to whom why
should I be happier why should I be have
less anxiety why should I feel more
understood and so like pretty much the
beginning of every ad for like Levitra
or whatever you know whatever the new
serotone you know s SSRI thing is it's
like they describe Humanity
they just say like are you hungry are
you tired are you horny are you like are
you dissatisfied in any way well the
Cure of that is a pill which I
wholeheartedly decry anything that gives
an if than statement for
happiness so like you will own nothing
and be happy like you want to say that
you're going to change my external
condition to change how I feel I just I
just reject it as a as any kind of if
then I will be happy but like the pill
overmedication part
I'm I've had too many people too close
to me ruin their lives topping from SSRI
SSRI and getting on cocktails of pills
and and and they've got a sleep Med and
they've got a wakeup Med
and they're just they're just a walking
Pharmacy it's crazy for people who
aren't American to look at the way that
America deals with this I remember so in
the UK just for context you can't get
prescribed
melatonin you can't buy it over the
counter you can't buy it on Amazon my
video guy when he flies over here takes
it back like some like he [__]
smuggle like he's Pablo Escobar but with
melatonin tablets instead like going
into CVS am I allowed to get this
uh that's the degree of difficulty that
it is to get prescribed anything
and in America the first place that
people turn when they have a problem is
the pill bottle I mean I have two
physician parents so like and I would
say Western you know for the most part
Western medicine through the just
believe in all Pharmaceuticals and all
that kind of stuff and so I've I grew up
really close to it my grandfather is a
physician so like just lots of medic
medicine in the family in general and I
um I just hate it I really do I don't
hate a lot of things but I really I
really I hate I hate what it does to
people and more the underlying thing is
that they reject Being Human and they
think there's something wrong with them
and so many people waste all of their
time trying to solve a problem that is
life rather than living it and it drives
me
nuts like they they they they search for
the medication rather than confronting
the problem like you don't have an
anxiety problem you need to deal with
whatever the thing you're worried about
is like I I mean man I have too many
controversial beliefs I'm getting into
much of it
like you drink a lot because you're
stressed if you de with the thing that
stresses you that's the trigger for you
drinking so yes there's addictive
properties to drinking I'm not going to
I'm not denying that but the thing that
leads the drinking the condition that
creates that that's something that you
can attack and so I think so little
attention is given to accepting reality
rather than saying there's something
wrong that people waste their entire
life searching for an answer that
doesn't exist what about it's normal to
not know what you're doing if you did it
wouldn't be called growth high-five your
fear uncertainty and doubt and carry
on if you knew what you were
doing then you would be stagnating
because you'd be doing nothing new and
so if you're going to do something new
then that is what would be the Catalyst
for growth and so you can't want to grow
and also want to know everything you're
doing at the same time it's like the two
beliefs contradict one
another and
so I think that's a lot of a lot of the
discontent that people suffer from is
they want two things that are Polar
Opposites they want the really strong
character they want the easy life like
one is the price of the other you have a
hard life to have great character you
have an easy life you have you have
shitty character everything came easy
you want to grow you don't want hardship
hardship creates
growth and so they want both and you
can't like it's it's wanting the Jordans
without paying the price they're the and
the price isn't bad it just the price is
what it is and so it's just do you want
the Jordans or not and if you do then
don't lament the price tag pay the price
tag and be happy you have the Jordans
and if you don't want the Jordans then
don't buy them
there's something in here is around
comparing the lessons that people who
have achieved success tell you about how
to also achieve success when they're
using that pattern which is well they
look like they know what they're doing I
should look like I know what I do I
should feel like I know what I'm
doing but you don't know what you're
doing right you're you're a white belt
and that person's a third degree black
belt in whatever it is that you're
trying to
pursue State the facts and tell the
truth
I mean my I mean the amount of you know
900 follower Instagram accounts that all
I see is people espousing advice on how
to grow their social media
following you're never going to win like
you don't get it like you like i' I've
been following like you don't get it
because the content of what you're
putting out sorry the evidence that
encapsulates your message disproves
literally everything you say before you
open your mouth and the thing is is that
people are obsessing about the algorithm
and this type of font and I should do
vertical format and I should do
horizontal format and I use this as an
analogy that you can draw to anything
but everyone has that friend who is a
train wreck on relationships who gives
relationship
advice it's just like it doesn't even
matter if the advice is good you're a
train wreck it's the fat friend who
gives viice on how to be fit it's just
like and they're like citing all these
studies and you should try these
supplements it's like you're a fat [__]
just shut up stop like there's don't
waste your breath no one is listening
and so it's just it's missing the big
obvious thing and so again it's like
that big Domino you're like I want to
get into fitness like there was a friend
of mine actually um who's in the fitness
space and he's like I really want to
grow my Fitness business and obviously
like I have books on it and I videos and
did that for a whole past life and um I
was like dude you're not in shape
he like but I know all these I was like
you don't look like someone that anyone
wants to look
like and so the thing is like for
whatever you're doing the big one thing
is like if you were look like a shredded
God you could say eat fried chicken
every day and people would buy your [__]
cuz like what's the one big Domino that
if I just did that everything else would
take care of itself do that and every
ounce of effort you're putting into not
doing that is a
waste basically the vshred
model actually really nice guys yeah
they're in Vegas well he's like Public
Enemy Number One for the fitness Bros
yeah what was your definition of trauma
that you taught me on the phone oh yeah
so um because this word is so thrown
around on social media my god um I was
like okay I have to Define this so that
I can try and like understand it um so I
believe trauma is when you have a
punishing event that permanently changes
Behavior that's it
so if you uh you know are a kid and you
touch the stove and you burn your hand
and you never touch a stove again you
were
traumatized now the thing is is that
that's a positive
consequence so is trauma
bad I don't know was the consequence bad
in that situation no and so a lot of
people use the this person traumatized
me as the as the the
transgression whereas the question is
what was the result of that quote trauma
because trauma is just accelerated
learning and so if you have PTSD for
example if you were abroad and had lots
of bombs going off then you had rapid
learning so you have trauma that
permanently changes your behavior around
loud noises and so you generalize loud
noises from this environment to now when
someone honks you you know freak out and
you think about those situations right
and
so just defining the world around me has
helped me navigate it a lot better so
that I can understand what we're talking
about because there are so many you know
people like trauma is a feeling in your
body that you have to you have to
release the trauma I'm like what the
[__] are you talking about you know
release trauma you changed Behavior due
to a stimulus that's it and so if you
want to change your behavior back you
create a new condition that reinforces
the new Behavior you want period because
otherwise we appeal to mysticism and we
just say lots of like nonsensical
[__] that the whole woo woo world is
all about I actually spoke at a woowoo
event which was really funny how did
that go uh surprisingly well I just
started by being like you will all
disagree with most of the things I say
but they uh they kind of mystici my my
nihilism so it worked out fine how' you
do that uh well because I just describe
actions and so they describe those
actions as attraction for what whatever
and I was like attract repel whatever if
you you know make 100 calls you'll have
more people who know who you are than if
you don't that's the same as putting out
an energetic frequency to the quantum
realm it's that saying that you want
money I have no idea what any of that
means dude there was
a podcast that I got linked to from a
girl in Austin who got inducted into
some weird cult that was sacrificing
period blood at the full moon so that
they could get birken bags
yeah Austin's a weird place so you you
were there for a while I was yeah well
too weird for me spat you up Alex I
appreciate you man thank you for coming
on what's next what can people expect
from you next few months um well all my
effort is in the the school games so
we're uh I mean I can talk about him I
cannot talk about him yeah um so yeah so
I I just made the biggest invest in my
life and now co-owner of school.com um
it's a platform where you can build what
you want to build learn what you want to
learn and uh schools will give you the
tools community in the education to help
you and so we've actually created a
whole thing where people can start all
this stuff for free um because I just I
believe my whole platform has been
education that's what I believe in um I
think the education system is broken and
um teachers don't get paid or given the
resources to actually teach students and
they're you know they're supposed to
teach tests that they know don't help
students students get educated on stuff
that doesn't matter in the real world
and they own amounts of debt for a piece
of paper that doesn't make them anything
to pay off the debt that they're in for
the rest of their lives and I just I
hate all of it which is why we started
making the content that we do and so um
this is one big investment that I'm
doing to try and make my small dent
towards helping fix that and I don't
like I obviously talk about business
that's what I know okay
um but one person can't can't do that
like I can't change I mean I can try you
know but like I I don't I don't think
one one person is going to change the
world and so um I wanted to invest in a
platform that would help other people do
that for one another and so whether it's
like you know how to paint and you want
to teach people to paint you know how to
fix Hondas and you want to teach people
to do that like there are so many more
useful skills that we can trade with one
another and I think Ben Franklin said
there's no more High there's no more
noble a deed than to help another no
more to educate and I I wholeheartedly
believe that and so so um I mean that's
what I'm investing my my dollars and my
time into and so um yeah that's that's
the that's like my whole next year in
terms of what I'm investing obviously
acquisition. we continue to invest we're
family office and so if you have a
business that you want to sell or scale
you can hit us up hell yeah I'm going to
enjoy watching it happen man appreciate
you thanks for having me on thank you
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode with Alex you will
love my 2-hour conversation with David
Goggins which you can watch right
here go on tap it